e
two minutes we're past our 9:30 start
time so uh start
seats
e
okay we're going to wait just a couple
more moments we still see a lot of empty
seats so we'll just give everybody a
moments I think we can uh talk about
even though we're not officially started
welcome our temporary subs today and I
will attempt to get all their names
correct representative Heath I know from
our my on finance
welcome uh representative spear I think
I got it right that time uh from
Commerce uh representative is it Muse or
Muse Muse Muse I I'm not sure what
welcome and representative Harriet Garo
I believe is down over here they are
subbing
for five of our
uh Missing D's today so did I miss
on I don't know we we have five five
Replacements you folks that are here
must not feel very
important have not been
words
guys don't mind I would love to make the
26 good on doing the
first I I think John do you
care okay that's what I thought I just
want to make sure that's why we put you
just okay uh we're going to get started
folks welcome everybody uh welcome to
all our subs again and uh let's start by
The Pledge and representative yella you
pledge
okay thank you representative
yella uh Mr clerk would you mind calling
the role
please or attendance role okay uh Vice
chairman power here represent Guthrie
clerk is here representative
Sal here representative Ella present uh
representative
Kelly representative aood present
representative Brown here representative
kahill here representative
Muse here representative Harriet
Phillips
okay uh representative Gilman here
representative jury here representative
Gallagher representative
Hicks representative Heath here
representative priest here
representative spear here and Mr
chairman present thank
you thank you Mr Clark okay we have a
very long list of bills today um as we
go through them they're there will be a
couple we're not going to exec today
just because we're expecting um further
amendments and uh we do have the 20th
the morning of that we will use to wrap
up and clean up uh probably one or two
maybe three
um we talked about the subs you're all
here except for hawen Phillips right now
I
guess and with that that we will
begin all right uh we'll open up the
executive session on HB uh
cac6 relating to local
governance and I have a motion
from I move itl representative yella
moves itl
representative like to Mo make a motion
to second that Mr chairman thank you
representative Brown yeah repres of
yella would you like to speak to
your
motion um yes I think that the uh the
prime
sponsor would like the uh State of New
Hampshire to not be uh a Dylan's rural
State and essentially uh trying to uh
put in the Constitution that they that
the local municipalities are um in
charge of of zoning um and the in the
state the conquered conquered actually
grants uh municipalities what they can
and cannot do with
zoning and the uh the language I believe
is UN
unworkable it's uh complicated as far as
it says that
um municipalities should have ultimate
power but then it dictates what they
should and should not do as far as um
variances and stuff like that and so um
of not clear as far as what what it
actually wants to do um as far as do
they have ultimate control or do they
not um and so for those reasons I will
not be able to support uh cacr 16 thank
you thank representative Brown do you
have something I your mic's still on
okay um representative majori I saw your
hand thank you Mr chairman I I agree
with the previous speaker about this and
would be supporting uh the itl I I
wondered if the idea of the bill was to
create the kind of transparency or
create a a lot of
transparency in in local government but
I cannot see how this language would
effectuate those ends and I actually
think it would make it more complicated
to provide the kind of honesty and and
and and all of the facts with this
language I just think it would be too
honorous and and too much of a problem
so I'll be supporting the
itl thank you representative PRI thank
you Mr chairman I will also be
supporting the itl motion and I agree
with the um statements that my the
fellow repres my fellow Representatives
have made so far and I would even go as
far as to say this would be a nightmare
to implement in the localities um
especially the fiscal impacts of
everything that comes up in the
communities I just don't think that's
feasible in New Hampshire thank you
comments seeing none we will ask the
clerk to call a rooll on the motion of
16 Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie clerk votes yes
representative lales
yes uh representative Joella yes
representative Kelly representative
awood yes representative Brown yes
representative kill
yes representative major yes
yes representative Muse yes
representative Harriet
Guthrie uh representative heckin
Phillips representative Gilman
yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks uh
hold on one second um representative
Gallagher cannot vote on this one he
okay representative
Hicks representative Heath
yes representative priest yes
representative
spia
yes and Mr chairman yes believe it's 16
to
zero okay 16 to zero so it without
objection we'll go on to consent uh
representative of lales we have you down
as the committee report Arthur you okay
certainly thank you very much okay
that'll close the exec session on CR CAC
cr16 uh we will go right into the next
one and that is HB 526 regulating the
use of temporary traffic control
Personnel um representative M oh I'll
wait for the clerk to be ready I'm sorry
I'm Russian again
okay uh for 526 uh representative
McDonald
thank you Mr chairman I would uh
recommend itl on this bill do we have a
that we have lots of seconds here
representative priest
seconds and representative McDonald
would you like to
speak uh thank you Mr chairman uh this
bill does not needed at this particular
time uh we received t a lot of testimony
against the bill plus the emails
against that I also question uh that
Authority Under
RSA 105 2-a the authority of the police
chief to uh if I can just find it here
shall the authority to direct to control
all employees of his or her Department
in the normal course of Duty and I think
this bill would contradict that current
RSA for the authority of the uh the
chief of police of the community that
they serve thank
you further comments representative
lales thank you Mr chairman
um I think this is a well-meaning
bill uh the problem as I see it is
that here in New Hampshire
currently the use of First
Responders is really Under Pressure so
this is not a good time to be messing
around with uh this sort of uh enactment
so I'll be voting for The
it representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman I will also be
voting for the
itl um I think as it's been stated so
far that this process is
already in in the in the regulations for
local
communities and with de
you representative
power thank you Mr chairman I I would
also concur with my colleagues on the
committee that um while this bill may be
well-intentioned that there are
concerns in that um the chief of police
has the responsibility to ensure and
oversee the safety of the travel in
public on roadways and I did have a
lengthy conversation I asked a lot of
questions of my police chief in the town
in which I reside and he explained the
process to me and it was very clear that
when there's work to be done the
contractor will contact the chief of
police and a lot of questions will be um
asked and the situation at hand with
regards to the work will be
analyzed lots of factors are taken into
account the location of where the work
will be conducted the nature of the
work um as well as the type of of
roadway and the police
chief working in the town has that that
knowledge as to the type of Road the
traffic um impacts the time of day so
therefore I I don't see
it it concerns me greatly that this bill
would take that oversight away from um
the person in the municipality who is
charged with um ensuring the public
safety so for those reasons I will be
supporting the itl thank you
representative
K thank you Mr chair um yes I I um
overwhelmingly will be supporting the
itl we we um we saw overwhelming
testimony from from online and with
phone calls and with people coming to
our committee about why we shouldn't go
forward with this with this bill and and
one of the things that we're trusted
with as members of this legislative body
is protecting the public and we need to
make sure that the people that can do
that the best are providing safety for
our for our people for that reason um
itl representative Gallagher um so so
I'd just like to note that the uh
previous time our committee held
executive session on this bill before um
it was recommitted to us we passed it
otpa 18 to1 uh it seemed to be a pretty
strong agreement that it was a good idea
then and basically what's changed is
since then is that the police have gone
mad and have bullied us out of
supporting us and as someone who um took
part in the uh in the protests against
police brutality and police power in
2020 uh I'm not going to be bullied
around like that so um I'm going
to uh stick with my previous vote on
this bill and
um oppose the itl motion on
comments
seeing none I I will just speak briefly
to it I I I understand this is going to
go nowhere in the committee which is
fine but um I do want to comment on a
few things uh the first thing is I I too
spoke with my uh Town manager and uh
chief of police and explained or asked
them to explain the how they actually go
about um Del uh giving Authority to the
chiefs of police now it may be different
in the big cities I'm not aware and
those are the only individuals we
actually heard from were uh City uh
individuals in fact when I asked one of
the individuals if he had who was the
ncpa I asked him if he had spoken to
anybody in the small commit uh
communities and they he said they hadn't
um anyway the way it works in um the
town of
barington is and it's always been this
way is that the chief of police does
make the decision the chief of police
though is subordinate to the town
manager who is also subordinate to the
uh select the select board so there is a
chain of command there um the I think
the original sponsors representative
Bickford's original intent was to
basically put into the
rsa's um
to give guidance to the towns that were
un unsure of how it should work um we
had one individual who actually made the
comment
that would this require him to re
convene the board of Selectmen every
time they wanted
a a police deal detail well that's I
mean simply silly I mean that this
wouldn't do that um the other big thing
is the deal T regulations actually
speak
to um other than class four or five
roads the CL the New Hampshire dot
Flagger requirements actually are for um
the dot which operates on anything but
class four or five roads it does however
say when they oversee class four five
roads then they should uh look at the uh
get a separate Municipal agreement blah
blah blah the point is that again I
think this was more of a clarifying type
of Bill rather than a changing of the
guidelines um I too will support it only
because
uh my name's on the
amendment with along with representative
Bickford um I I totally understand the
rest of the committee's uh r against it
we'll accept that representative kill
you have something else yeah thank you
Mr chair I just I just wanted to speak
to the reason why we um when we have
these bills involving law enforcement
why we see big city um departments
represented well it's because these
small departments don't have the staff
to send people to come here um we did
have a member of the Hamstead Police
Department testify at our last hearing
and they're a very small Department um
but in most cases they don't have the
staff to send someone down here to
represent the Departments
and that's why I think that
happens further comments questions
rot yes sir uh HB 526 FN
itl Vice uh chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
yeah uh the cler votes yes with a
notation that he has not been B bullied
or pushed by any Police Department any
police officer in the state of New
Hampshire to vote itl on this
lales representative yella
no representative Kelly Representative
awood
no representative Brown yes
representative
kahill
yes representative majority yes
representative
Muse
yes representative Harry GTH yes
representative hackin
Phillips okay representative Gilman
yes representative Gallagher
no representative
Hicks representative Heath
yes representative priest
yes representative spear yes
and Mr chairman
to4 okay 12 to4 um is there an objection
consent I see none so it will go on
consent and representative McDonald you
would be happy to write the committee
report certainly Mr chairman okay thank
you very much uh that'll close close the
526 and Mr clerk when you are ready to
one okay
sir represent power you have a comment
yes thank you Mr chairman um I will
reiterate um the importance of members
when they cast their votes to please
make sure that their their mics are on
and they're speaking into the mic
because I continue to get feedback from
members of the public who are watching
this um live streamed
and we they cannot hear all members
thank you excellent point okay uh we go
ahead and open up the exec session on HB
1053 relative to permissible residential
units in a commercial Zone do we have a
motion representative priest I see your
hand thank you Mr chairman I move that
we
1053 I
will representative Gilman second sorry
representative major she beat you to it
uh representative priest would you like
to speak to
this Mike you you flipped it the other
way I'm sorry Mr chairman thank you um
in New Hampshire we have local control
and this bill would be taking away that
uh
responsibility communities right now
have the option to Zone known portions
of their communities as mix use
communities both commercial and
residential and many communities have
done this so it's already in it's
already in the process second there
would be unintended consequences if we
mandated that all commercial zones be
allow residential
uses um as I was re talking to one of my
fellow repres resentatives today
Manchester uh has this kind of mixed
zoning and as soon as the residential
came into their building they left and
so we now have a vacancy where a very
strong business was once and and no
longer is so there are reasons why we
have commercial districts and why
residential isn't a part of it and I
think that should be kept to local
control and their planning boards and
their Selectmen to make sure that that
is appropriate use for those areas thank
you thank you for the
comments representative Gallagher I'll
be opposing the itl motion on this um I
think we need a house or we have a
housing crisis right now we need to um
loosen zoning restrictions to make it
easier to build new housing or to allow
people to occupy existing structures if
you've got a business leading leaving
then fine that's just more room for
housing we need housing more than we
need businesses right now um so um yeah
I think this is a good bill idea um as
far as it uh taking away local control
good um the thing is local control
basically allows nimes to stop housing
projects and we've seen it abused time
and time again to make this housing
crisis worse the whole principle of loal
control were working fine we would not
be in this housing crisis that we're in
right now so we we need
to we we need to stop being inthrall to
that principle and need to try some new
approaches um this bill would be a one
of those good new approaches um and I
try representative
majority oh you're up thank you Mr
chairman um I will be supporting the uh
the itl on this although I do think the
bill um I do think the intent behind the
bill was was very good but as as my
friend who made the motion said I I
think we will have I think that there
will be unattended consequences with
having issues where you have a
commercial Zone that suddenly now you're
going to have to put a round peg into a
square hole when it comes to that kind a
zoning if if the the bill says that
building now shall have no more stricter
regulations than it would for a
residential you're going to you're not
only going to have a mixed use you're
going to have mixed zoning and mixed
regulations I I think you're going to
create a problem if you have an A an
application coming in for mixed use then
then you have an issue where you can
look at this comprehensively but if
you're trying to do it peace meal while
I agree that affordable housing finding
more affordable housing is important and
this might get us there I think this
bill will have more problems then it
you representative kahill thank you Mr
chair I I I think my colleague
representative majori eloquently said
that and I agree with everything you
just said and you know to the point of
local control local control is what got
each one of us representing our people
here today I mean they they put us here
um you know so local control isn't all
that
bad for the comments representative
Gilman I'm sorry supposed to call you n
oh thank you Mr chair um with all
respect to my uh colleague uh
representative Gallagher I agree that we
need to use all the tools we can for uh
increasing our housing our housing stock
a diverse housing stock um however this
is uh time and time again we hear um
mandated zoning doesn't work for every
town you know my town has 15,000 people
in it one town has 800 they might not
have the opportunities that we do and if
we tell them they have to do this um it
it just might not work and then there
will be lawsuits and you know the
unintended consequences that my other uh
colleagues have spoken of uh so I will
be supporting an itl in this Bill thank
you
representative Guthrie thank you Mr
chairman I would like to say that uh the
housing shortage so-called housing
shortage is used as a disguise sometimes
to interfere with local zoning I think
local zoning is local for a reason I
think the the particularly when you have
a legislation that say shell a matter of
right uh I don't think that's uh the
States uh business uh each town is
different uh the cities certainly are
different than the towns and the thing
say that the the same shoe will fit all
feet is is just just doesn't make sense
to me and I will be voting against I'm
sorry in favor of the
itl further
comments seeing none I'll make two quick
ones uh I can't I can say I don't think
I've ever been in more agreement than
with representative priests than uh than
right now
um
uh anytime I see a bill that says As a
matter of right which compels top down
zoning um I I I'm against I mean it's
just something that that I'm not willing
to do um the the one thing that I asked
uh Ben Frost of New Hampshire housing um
at the end and I I think I asked home
almost every time when we have one of
these matter of right
bills and that
was absent this bill can the local towns
and
municipalities change their zoning to
accommodate this because we know many of
them already do this and he of course
smiled and said yes so the towns have
the ability to do the municipalities
have the ability to do this now if they
wish and I local control is where where
we need to keep it for the
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
roll thank you Mr
chairman Vice chairman
power the motion is itl correct yes I'm
sorry yes representative
Guthrie clerk votes yes representative
lales yes representative Kella no okay
representative Kelly um representative
awood yes representative Brown yes
representative
kahill
yes representative majori
yes representative Muse yes
representative Harry Guth
yes representative Hain
Phillips representative Gilman yes
representative Gallagher
representative Heath
yes representative priest yes
representative Speer
yes and Mr chairman
yes 15- two I
believe okay 15- two without objection
that will uh representative yella object
correctly oh sorry about that no you're
then little uh tired this morning thank
you uh representative yella objects it
will not go on consent there we go uh
representative priest I'm G to we're
trying to figure that
out I got it all right all right
representative majority I just thought
representative priest did such a great
little speech that he would be uh
writing the
report okay and uh for the
okay okay with that that closes the exec
1053 and once the clerk is ready we will
okay we're gonna open up exec on
hb101 establishing a committee to study
potential State programs to make loans
and on and on do we have a motion
representative majority thank you Mr
chairman I would move ought to pass pass
on House Bill
[Music]
1101 do we have a second on that
representative PRI representative majori
would you like to speak yes thank you Mr
chairman
um while there may be some R well there
may be some reluctancy I'm a little
tired too I guess um to create
additional study committees if there is
the energy and the passion to go ahead
and do this I think the cause is worthy
um um anytime that we can
address the affordable housing which
this bill tries to do and tries to look
at what we could do for Relief on
student loans um I think this is I think
this is an enormous bite out of the
Apple um but I would love to see the the
steps to to address both of these
situations uh and if there is the uh if
we do have the people who are willing to
sit on that commit and undertake this
worthy effort I think they should be
you further comments representative
priest did you have a hand up yes thank
you Mr chairman I will also be
supporting the OTP on this bill um even
though I there even though there are
existing programs in New Hampshire such
as um the neighbor Works Southern
neighbor works of Southern New Hampshire
and the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority that do exactly what this bill
does for the housing component of it I
believe that a study committee to look
into other means of helping to
finance um affordable housing as well as
to address the um the
burdensome of student loans and how we
you representative
lalis yes um thank you Mr chairman um
anytime I see something like student
loans lopped in with a
housing
issue I'm reminded of the high school
graduate who went to a trade school and
then mortgaged everything he had to buy
a construction
vehicle and he
he's in loans up to his eyeballs so that
he can make a
living I I just look at the
unfairness of a person who legally
obligates them themselves to acquire a a
college
education which does not provide
enough uh monetary Advantage for them to
pay back their student loans I cannot
support anything that lumps those two
things together so I will be voting
against this thank
you represent kill thank you Mr chair um
you know while I agree
with we have issues and problems that we
need to solve there's already a great
program that solves both of these issues
at the same time um and that would be
the US Army or the US Air Force where
you could get affordable housing and get
your student loans and get paid to have
a job at the same time um so there there
are options already out there uh you
departments representative Gilman thank
you Mr chair uh I support this um this
bill because of the uh testimony that we
received about people having to make a
choice over uh paying for their housing
or paying off their student loans at a
which um tend to be at a higher rate of
also uh yeah both of which hinder having
savings to to um make other choices like
buying new vehicles for the construction
business this doesn't say anywhere that
it's only for student loans for colleges
there also is money required for trade
schools and to your point uh
representative of this solutions of
joining the armed services there's also
evidence that people living on uh armed
services wages are still getting uh food
stamps and other support from public
services so I think that an interim
study to make sure that this is a smooth
and uh um
appropriate um makeup of the Loan
program uh whether together or
separately uh is a is an appropriate
thing to do right now to to go along
with the housing bills and and the other
affordability bills that we have coming
up so I will be voting to support this
thank
you for the uh representative Guthrie do
you have your hand up thank you Mr
chairman I also would be concerned about
combining uh uh low uh rent uh interest
in income interest loans for the uh uh
education for for for combining the two
of them I don't think they're compatible
uh I think that both subjects could be
overwhelming and maybe if it was broken
up as a separate bill I would have more
uh sympathy for it but I really can't uh
support a bill that that comb combines
these two it just doesn't seem a a way
to
go uh representative haret
gas thank you Mr chair
um I don't really look at this as a bill
this is requesting a committee that
people take a look at this I don't think
that um us sitting around the table
really can answer for this either
whether it's the loan for um college or
whether it's um a
mortgage I don't see that as being out
function right now but I do believe a
committee it it would help if a
committee could be available to take a
look at those things and if it doesn't
work out fine but this is an opportunity
to do something for people that really
need
comments seeing none I'll add a quick
two cents here um
as somebody mentioned there already many
programs that exist to cover these two
issues um one not mentioned is basically
debt consolidation companies that exist
for this kind of thing uh my general
problem with it I I I will be voting
against the motion and that is the
establishing of yet another
committee
um as representative majori mentioned if
we can find people willing to sit on it
well I I see nine individual or is it
maybe 10 that are
sponsors of the bill I'm
always I always wonder why not the
individuals who are the sponsors
actually do the research and come
forward with a bill to actually make
this happen what they want to see happen
and rather than passing the uh
responsibility to you know to somebody
else
um to me that would be the the better
way to handle this um again uh study
commissions study committees
um we have several hundred right now in
the house and most of them never even
meet or accomplish anything so I just on
that alone I'll be against
this further comments
represent Gilman thank you Mr chair um I
did neglect to to point out that this
was uh to establish a committee to study
the potential of doing these of
combining these things or making them
separate um and I know that we have many
um committees and commissions that have
been ineffective or have not met um but
we have a
committee to study the Committees and
commissions and cut that out this is one
I think has been a topic for a number of
years and has a uh a purpose that we've
been talking about more and more this
year um how to make things affordable
for the people of New Hampshire uh so I
will be supporting the
OTP further comments I see none we would
ask the clerk to call a role on the
motion of
OTP on House Bill
thank you Mr chairman uh Vice chairman
power
no representative
Guthrie cler votes no Representative
lales no representative Kella
no Kelly Representative aood
no representative Brown no
Representative kahill
no representative majori yes
representative Muse yes representative
Harry Guth yes representative hackin
Phillips representative Gilman yes
representative
Gallagher
yes representative Hicks representative
Heath
yes representative priest yes
representative spia
yes and Mr chairman no
to8 8 to n correct we'll take past n to
eight good try
representative um do we have another
motion
representative yes I'd like a m make a
motion to itl on HB 11 one do we have a
second on that representative uh Brown
seconds yes I'd like to second that Mr
chairman um do you have anything new to
add representative
kill I do I I think
that these ideas separate could have
been something that um there could have
been more compromise on looking at if
these two issues were separate um but
because they're together I think there's
some some dangerous complications there
so for the comments I see none
representative PRI I agree with my
fellow representative uh K Hill on this
um that it would be advisable to
separate both of these issues into two
committees uh because of the
complexities of them but I will be
Ling further
comments I see none represent uh Mr
clerk when you're ready could we call
1101 Vice chairman power yes
representative
Guthrie click votes yes representative
lales yes representative Kella yes
representative Kelly representative
Arwood yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill
yes Representative
majori
no representative muse no representative
Harry Guth no representative hackin
Phillips okay representative Gilman
no representative
Gallagher
no representative Hicks representative
Howland I'm representative Heath I'm
sorry no representative Priest No repres
yes and Mr chairman yes motion passes uh
to7 okay this one will not go on the
um committee report
for our side representative Cahill are
you willing to write the committee
report since you made the motion yep
absolutely very good good and for the
minority J you want one I'll it and
minority and with that uh that'll close
the um exec on 1106 which I just thought
of something everybody um who's going to
be writing
reports this is very important I need
them by noon
tomorrow okay because we got to get
these in
uh for Wednesday to get them into the
calendar and the individual who's
responsible for getting those in me I
have jury duty all day Wednesday so we
have to have these in by noon
tomorrow I think you just miss stated
that we concluded 11:06 we conclude 1101
1101 thank you yes you're
uh
oh oh
there all right when the clerk gives me
the nod we will go ahead with our next
one I'll set very good we'll open up the
executive session on HB
11106 relative to net asset limits under
the elderly property tax exemption and
we will look to representative yok Kella
for a
motion I move
itl do we have a second I second that Mr
chairman representative Brown seconds
representative yella would you like to
speak sure um the sponsor of this bill
indicated that he was just trying to
raise it um the
minimum because of inflation however
municipalities already have the option
to raise ITC for whatever reason
inflation or just because they want to
um give more relief so I think that this
is
unnecessary um and if those if the
communities that are currently at the
minimum um want to stay there I'm not
sure that that we should be forcing them
to increase that um requirement so for
those reasons I think that uh this bill
needed further comments representative
major thank you Mr chairman um I agree
uh with the comments that were just said
um it would be great if we could have a
bill that had a trigger in it that
anytime you know that anytime inflation
went up or or we could raise these
things to some to some uh index uh but
the communities have that responsibility
they have that Authority they have that
flexibility to do that and I think that
should stay there if that was the only
thing happening in this bill I think we
might even be able to have a deeper
conversation but it goes even further
than that and I think that the new
definitions open up another can of worms
uh or open up additional cans of worms
that may again have unint consequences
and um so I I get where the sponsor
wants to go to give relief to uh to this
group of individuals but I think this
bill will cause problems thank
you thank you further comments
representative
gri thank you Mr chairman these this
issue was taken up at the local level
with a warrant article so every town has
a chance to vote on whether or not they
want to in increase the uh items in
curan elderly exemption so I feel more
comfortable having it handle at the
local level particularly where it has to
go through an a waren article means that
the towns towns people have a chance to
vote on it so uh I don't think this is
necessary and I'll uh support
itl very
good seeing no more comments when the
clerk is ready we call a rooll on the
motion of it
1106 okay Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yeah collect
votes yes represent
lales okay represent Kella
yes representative Kelly representative
awood yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill
yes representative majori
yes represent Muse yes representative uh
Harry goth yes representative hackin
yes read something else representative
Gallagher
yes uh representative Hicks
representative Heath yes representative
priest yes representative
spear yes and Mr chair
yes uh itl motion passes 16 to Zer thank
you Mr clerk this will go on the consent
unless there's an objection I see no
objections uh let's see
you
representative yella made the motion do
or I
can
okay representative yella will write the
report on that
one okay with that that closes
1106 Mr clerk you let me know when
you're
ready
okay
uh I believe representative hackin
Phillips has arrived good morning
welcome all right we'll go ahead and
open up the uh exec session HB 1175
relative to the official ballot
referendum form of
meetings I believe representative power
has something thank you Mr chairman I
1175 motion is odd to pass do we have a
second representative yell second
representative
power thank you Mr chairman um the
official ballot referendum form of town
meeting commonly known as SP2 was signed
into law in 1995 that's 30 years ago
and from
1995 up until
2019 Based on data on um that I was able
to obtain on the um Dr website
152 political subdivisions have adopted
theb2 form of town
meeting now in
2019 the statute was well let me just
back up so just just to be clear um the
question to adopt the SP2 form of town
meeting when this was signed into
law the question was placed on the
official ballot which meant that voters
were able to vote upon that
question on on Election Day at the polls
in the privacy of the the um the voting
booths
to be clear changing from a
traditional um form of town meeting to
SP2 is is a serious
consideration and therefore it it it's
incumbent upon the political subdivision
to have as many people weighing in on
that decision so um back to
2019 there was a bill introduced that
was signed into law which removed the
question to adopt sb2 from the official
ballot and instead to have that question
to be voted upon at the traditional Town
town
meeting so since that
time starting in
2020 there have been a total of 31 um
attempts to pass
SP2 and
30 of those have failed and only
one has been successful in making that
change so we should just really look at
that and and ask ourself you know what's
going
on when for 30
years these questions have been placed
on the official ballot and
um attempts were in fact
and it makes no sense to me um as to why
this statute was changed and furthermore
it is illogical to
me that whether or not you agree with
SP2 that's a separate issue some people
like it some people don't there's pluses
and there's minuses that's not the issue
at hand the issue at hand is the method
by which the question to ad where where
was that placed is it on the official
ballot like it had been from the
beginning
or since or
do or should it be as as it is um to be
voted upon at the traditional town
meeting then and there simply by a a
card vote I would say that that that
that's problematic because it makes no
sense that a person has to go to a
meeting that they really can't go to to
say that we don't want to go to the
meeting we want to we want to be able to
vote on warrant
articles on Election Day on Town
election day on the official ballot so
for those reasons um I would ask the
committee to support the motion of a to
pass thank
you representative majority thank you Mr
chairman um
yes in 2019 um I was going to say we but
this body Municipal and County uh had
this bill uh it passed Municipal and
County by a vote of 18
to1 um it passed in the house on the
floor by a vote of 235 to 122 and then
it passed in the Senate on a Voice vote
before it was signed into law um clearly
the our colleagues on uh our our
colleagues our colleagues on the other
side of the wall and the governor all
supported uh the idea of of the current
statute that we have now uh I would also
say that um when we look at the folks
who want to to change when we look at
the intent of the bill this is an
opportunity to have a discussion about
how you want your Ballot or how you want
to vote in your town continue to do it
that way um I don't see how putting it
on the ballot is going to uh Empower any
more people and when I look at the
number of Warrant articles that have
failed I also wonder I think people like
the current situation or the current
conditions the way they are so by the
very fact that this body the body on the
other side of the wall the governor all
supported what we have currently the
fact that so many bills have failed to
change it I think that um the bill
should be rather than OTP
thank you thank you very much further
comments representative y
Kell thank you I do I do believe that
there are some people that are
disenfranchised by this method of
choosing people that are not able to
attend of a
prolonged uh town meeting and um people
that are out of the state at the time of
the meeting people that are um overseas
at the time of the meeting all of those
people are disenfranchised from being
able because there is no absentee ballot
process in the town meeting style um of
of meeting all those people that would
utilize
absentees uh ballots are disenfranchised
from this taking part in that vote and
also um I think
that I think both sides are are are
referencing the number of times that
people um vote on this issue in a
municipality before it gets adopted and
I don't think that um I think that in my
municipality um we voted on it I think
six times before we adopted it and
that's because it is a significant
change and there is a little bit of a
learning curve about what it actually
means and what it actually entails and
um
in but but just because it took six
times to pass in my municipality or
thereabouts um it it has been completely
embraced since then and there's not a uh
not a chance that we would be going back
to the the the traditional town
meeting uh way um even with the some
drawbacks that I do see and I keep on
bringing up about the Min the default
budget being an issue um I think that
you know even with that problem in the
in the
sb2 formor I think it's a net benefit um
to those people
that um don't want to or not able to to
spend prolonged amount of time at at the
town
meeting thank
you representative
Elwood thank you Mr chairman um I'm
originally from Washington DC and moved
to New Hampshire in
2006 I attended um the first town
meeting uh and was
shocked I was shocked by the
behavior um of the you know moderator
who had no control
people's right to free speech was
trampled um there was Acts of
intimidation and afterwards I asked
numerous people why they didn't attend
and they simply
said because they would be retaliated
against and um this this sent me into
the
stratosphere as to trying to
understand how this form of government
uh was Democratic at all so I I support
the
OTP further comments representative
power thank you Mr chairman I I I would
like to just add three more points here
the first point being that the
legislature was different the
composition of the legislature was
different than it is today back in 2019
when this bill
um to
change the question to adopt being on
the official ballot it's different so
that we can't really um to me that's not
a valid argument secondly um again I'd
like to reiterate this is an important
um
decision for these political
subdivisions and
therefore when we have greater
participation in in in making this
decision that is that occurs by having
the question on the official ballot and
people can vote on it on Election Day I
would I think that most people can agree
if you're intellectually honest that we
have a better outcome and a better you
know assessment as to whether a
political subdivision subdivision wants
this change or not when we have more
people casting their votes
and the last thing that I would um point
out is curiously in 2019 when a bill was
passed to change this for some unknown
reason the bill failed to also change
the question to rescind and pull that
place it you know remove it from the
official ballot and put it back in the
town meeting
so House Bill 1175
restores the Equitable standards to
adopt as well as to resend and I think
that's another important point Thank
You representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman I will be opposing the a to
pass motion um because I think this is a
very important step for communities to
make and then there needs to be
discussion and debate among them and
before they vote and make this decision
you representative power thank you Mr
chairman I would like to clarify one
point yes I I absolutely agree with my
um colleague who just made a comment
with regards to debate and discussion
and um there is ample opportunity for
this and there's hearings that that are
to be held when when
arises repres uh excuse me
representative
lales yes uh when I first moved to New
Hampshire and new in uh
1979 and started attending Town meetings
I thought that wow this is amazing
unlike uh my colleague representative
award I was very impressed by the town
meeting the give and take and the the uh
contributions uh from all sides uh and
uh man against wife and brother against
brother I thought it was amazing and I
thought it was the purest form of
democracy uh ever devised by man uh and
when sb2 came around I was uh I was not
a a proponent of it because of of the
fact that people don't need to go to
town meeting they can simply go to their
uh election to the polls and make their
voice heard but I have come around now
to the to the point that I see that sb2
has has gotten much more particip IP
ation then uh it doesn't have the
entertainment value of the traditional
town meeting but it it does uh uh allow
for uh people to debate uh by going to
deliberative sessions and then it opens
the uh the voting up to people who uh
for whatever reason cannot ATT attend an
extended town meeting so I think the the
vote the bill here to allow people to
vote uh through the polls of whether to
go to sb2 or or retain the the uh
traditional town meeting I I think
that's a good thing and so I will be uh
supporting the
bill represent majority thank you Mr
chairman as always anytime my friend
from Lichfield says something I agree
with him and and enjoy his conversation
and his uh and and the and everything
that you put behind it knowledge and
experience and agreed with 75% of
everything you just said now um I think
that this that the town meeting form of
government is the truest form of
government and should I would like it to
be maybe ignorantly the time when the
community comes out and if they come out
with rotten apples and tomatoes so be it
if it's brother against brother husband
against wife so be it but I think this
opportunity to discuss this in public to
discuss this with your with your friends
and your residents is is the place for
this and doing it on the ballot I don't
see how it's going to get that much more
because you are going to drive people to
the town meeting when you do it this way
and I think that's what we should be
uh representative El uh representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair um I was
tossed up on this question but having
experienced SP2 for just about my entire
voting life I think yeah my entire
voting life
um there is still the the opportunity
for what feels like the traditional town
meeting and that's called the
deliberative session and the people that
attend the deliberative session are the
ones that have the power to make the
changes that they may want to make um
and I'm sorry for those that don't go to
the deliberative session but it's the
same as uh not showing up at a town
meeting so I I have to um oppose the OTP
because uh the sb2 actually did very
little to change the town except for
allowing more people to have a vote in
the end or make it convenient I suppose
it's more of a convenience factor um but
they still the the 50 people that show
up at the deliberative session still
have the same Authority and the same
power as the 50 people that show up at a
you just so everybody in the room knows
I've most of you many of you don't
normally sit here so the way I kind of
go about recognizing people at first I
kind of alternate between Democrats and
Republicans then I also um go by who's
spoken and who is not so if you see me
kind of going out of order to what
you're used to that's the reason I do it
that way and with that I'll
representative kahill is up thank you Mr
chair um I too like my my colleague
moved up from Washington DC in 2006 and
um you know I just wanted to add to this
discussion that our deliberative
sessions at least in in my town and my
observation is our deliberative sessions
I've seen some good deliberative
sessions it's really great getting to
know the people really talk to them but
man oh man there's less and less
participation in the deliberative
sessions um and I'm not sure why that is
but I just just wanted to point out that
we're getting less and less
people representative
Elwood thank you Mr chairman so our town
uh went to
sb2 and yes uh the deliberative sessions
are well
attended um it's far more
civilized and in fact I insisted that
they have rules of procedure to hold the
deliberative session which they did so I
I think the atmosphere between the
traditional town meeting in SP2
deliberative session
um was more workable it was more
welcoming
comments seeing none we will ask the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
aop pass relative uh on HP
1175 Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie CCT votes yes
representative sales yes representative
Keller yes represent Kelly
representative Arwood yes representative
Brown yes representative
kahill
yes Representative majori
no representative muse
no representative Harry Guth no
representative hackin Phillips
no representative Gilman no
representative Gallagher
no representative hick representative
how representative Heath I'm sorry no
representative Priest No representative
spear no Mr chairman
yes motion fails nine to n is there an
alternative motion that would like to be
presented representative major Mr
chairman I I will move uh itl
on this bill do we have a second on that
representative pre
seconds um I'm assuming we need no
further discussion the only question I
have is what happens if we get the same
vote we have one further motion that can
be made if that okay motion is also tied
then it would go to the floor without
recommendation
you when the clerk is is there any
discussion on this motion seeing none
when the clerk is ready call the roll
thank you Mr chairman uh Vice chairman
power no representative Guthrie click
votes no represent lales no represent
Kella no Kelly uh represent Hardward no
representative Brown no Representative
kahill
no
representative majori yes representative
Muse
yes representative Harry Guth yes
representative hacken Phillips yes
yes uh representative hacken Phillip can
I get your yours again please yes okay
uh representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks representative
Heath yes representative priest yes
representative spe yes Mr chairman no N9
to9 is there a further motion that
anybody would like to make such as
no Mr chairman you have a motion I would
like to move interim study Mr chairman
do we have a second on
again Is there further discussion
representative lales question of the
chair so if we voted interim study it
would go to the floor as interim study
now would the
house o on the floor be able to vote
down interim study and vote one way or
correct repr major and thank you Mr
chairman and if interim study does pass
I I I certainly believe that there will
be plenty of people who would like to
sit on this and and do the work because
it is an important issue um I'm sure we
people representative yella did I open
up a can of
worms I mean I it begs the question what
work do you believe is necessary if if
the if we've done it this way for you
know almost 30 years and we've and we've
done the other way for almost two years
what what is there more information
could we possibly have on that topic
representative majori would you be would
you be open to resending your your
motion and letting we could let this go
no well no let's let's go we'll take if
we can thank you Mr chairman for the
opportunity I would like it to to take a
vote on the interim study and let's see
what we got okay very good further
comments uh represent Gall um yeah I
just think that since the um both the
OTP and the itl votes both tied nine to
n that um opinions are already pretty
set and Stone this and I don't think
that interm stud is really going to
change much of anything um but um I mean
I'm I'm open to it so um I guess being
later in the RO roll call I'll just see
going I'm inclined to agree with my
colleague representative yella I mean
it's it's
to me it's black and white you either
believe in taking it to the ballot or
you don't I mean we've had lots of
experience with this I I will not
support interim study because I don't I
don't know what could be gained by
it okay s see seeing no further
questions so L the clerk call a rooll on
okay Vice chairman in power no
representative Guthrie no click votes no
Representative lales
no representative Kela
no representative Arwood no
representative Brown no representative
kill
no
uh representative majori yes
representative Muse yes representative
harri Guth yes representative hackin
Phillips yes representative
Gilman yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative Heath yes
representative priest yes representative
spear yes Mr chairman no
uh nine to nine okay my whole intent was
going through all those three motions
was just to exhaust the emotions
available to us so uh three votes of n-
n uh this will go on the uh regular
calendar as uh without
recommendation um who would like to a
representative power will write the
report and I would expect represent
majority write the other one yes sir am
I ask a question of the chair when
you're ready yeah sure just on the for
the calendar it'll say no recommendation
what will it say for the
vote I think it'll I think it'll say 99
I'd have study no it this is without
recommendation so it won't say anything
so with that folk we'll close the
executive session on 1175 and the next
time the chair says ask about an interim
them okay um we're actually moving along
quite well is everybody doing well or do
we like a five or minute break or
everybody's good okay I'll tell you what
let's just want to do one more a break
yeah after yeah let's just do one more
um just so everybody knows uh HB there
are two bills that we will not exec
today there potentially more but two we
won't that we will do on the 20th and
that is uh this next one that on the
list HB 1181 that's because um we've
received a couple of amendments that I
was told we would be receiving and we
just got them now they're too detailed I
think to reasonably expect us to go
through them and vote on them the other
one will be HB 1223 which is the uh
historic horse racing uh that one also
we have a very lengthy one pending and
allegedly all parties are working
together to see if they
can come to an agreement on that so
those two will be postponed so with that
we will go ahead and open up the exec
session on 1187 uh
1187 relative to prohibiting lease
agreements of equipment for building and
facility
improvements I recognize representative
power thank you Mr chairman I would like
to offer to this committee um amendment
number 2024
d-10
26h that's uh yeah an amendment to House
Bill
what was that number again
please it is
d126
H thank you and do we have a second on
that I'll second that Mr chairman
representative Brown seconds
representative power do you like to
speak thank you Mr chairman so um I
filed this this bill obviously during
the filing period and it was a
um involved bill that had many parts and
pieces to it and I did
work a lot with the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association to
um come up we had the discussion and
there were some some
concerns and I worked very um very hard
to come up with to revise it based on
their feedback addressing their concerns
because whenever I um file any bills
it's never my intent to break anything I
I just my intent is to improve things so
like I said um I worked very closely
with
nhma there was a lot of back and forth
there were several um
aversions and as we came upon the
hearing I submitted an amendment
based on the latest version that that we
had collaborated on and that is what I
brought to this committee so after the
hear you know after the hearing and
listening to the testimony and the
feedback and the questions that this
committee asked I then um took that
under advisement and seriously
considered all of that information and
that's how I arrived at the amendment in
front of you so basically what this
Amendment does is it retains only one uh
uh well one major aspect of the bill as
filed and that is
um dealing with the the concern of the
the loophole in which
um school districts
and mostly that I had seen taking
advantage of this loophole in which they
were take they were putting lease
agreements with Escape Clauses on the
really returnable under an escape clause
for a lease agreement they they were
fixed items such as Windows HVAC
flooring
Etc and it really didn't make any sense
and when when you looked at the statute
um governing this
section the it was a clear leap loophole
that un
that was a go around for a provision in
another um area of Statute where it says
that a lease of goods that are
fixtures or may continue Goods that
but the there was just another section
Con that there was a loophole so I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to close
that
and the other thing that this amendment
does is it it just defines as a lease
article so I hope I I I hope that I
enough representative kahill thank you
Mr chair um you know I think what we're
trying to solve here is a loophole um
that has
allowed a workaround on the will of the
taxpayers potentially um for example in
in my town currently we're putting in a
solar project and
some wood boilers that use wood and
we're doing it with this this lease
agreement you know so I question the
superintendent on and I want to talk to
him and I was like are we doing this as
a lease and he was like oh yeah yeah
yeah we're we're potentially spending
more taxpayer
money to accomplish something that we
could do if we just purchase them
outright with a traditional Warren
article these leases these lease
agreements tend to you know you you go
down the rental store and you you lease
a TV you're going to spend more than the
cost of the TV if you rent it for a year
you know what I mean these lease
agreements I think aren't a beneficial
thing for the actual taxpayers it might
be good to get your little idea done but
I don't think it's a wise use of
money represent
Brown thank you Mr chairman uh I just
experienced this uh this past weekend
with our school board and M bur and uh
the the first uh warrant was to go ahead
and bond the work and do the work like
it would normally be done as was
intended by the law uh that didn't pass
so they went to the know fourth or fifth
warrant on the for the school board and
they attempted to pass it uh and and
what would have happened is it would
have cost the taxpayers another $800,000
to do this work U so I spoke about it
and and how the fact that this is an
apparent loophole that initially this
was supposed to be used for buying fire
trucks or other heavy equipment that
town that the town might need and could
return if the lease Provisions didn't
work out this type of equipment as
representative kahill indicated was for
solar panels that was also a 19-year
payback 19 years so it certainly didn't
justify in face value anyways but it was
an attempt to move forward with
something that uh wasn't reasonable that
would have initially been a lower cost
uh but on the long term would have been
significantly higher so fortunately they
didn't pass it um the only difference
between what the representative power
and what I would like to do is I would
have liked to have had this uh this
situation covered by a super majority as
well but she decided to do this as a
simple procedure it would just be very
clear as to what we were attempting to
do with this and I appreciate what she's
done so thank
you further comments representative
Maori thank you Mr chairman um I thank
my friend from Brookline for putting the
work into this if there is a loop well
there there seemingly is a loophole in
some municipalities as we heard in the
hearing as we are are hearing now it
seems that the amendment is responsive
to what was heard in the hearing it
seems the amendment is responsive
um to concerns uh raised concerns that
are raised and as such since the
amendment closes that
loophole and that's all that this does
then I can support the amendment and i
would support the bill as
amended thank you thank you further com
excuse me further comments or
questions seeing none uh I have one
question for the amendment sponsor on
line 21 or 20 and
21 without pulling out the RSA and
looking up on the laptop here does the
issuance or continu continuation of
lease agreements have any
dollar value attached in other words if
they um had a lease agreement uh for say
$500 with that still
sure um thank you Mr chairman so that
section two of the amendment that just
pertains to um adding into the list of
articles lease agreements that's that's
all that that
does correct and
uh follow I'll follow it up it adds into
the
definition but the current definition is
appropriation for the amount to be
raised by the issuance of bonds or notes
which are generally high dollar
items the I mean I understand what
you're trying to do with close a
loophole and I'm totally in agreement
with this I just want to make sure that
we're
not doing something there that has
that the intent isn't
correct um does it make
sense so these lease agreements they
they're they're
multi-e
so I'm not sure that I'm compro
comprehending your question but I I did
work very closely with nhma as well as
with OS and I'm confident that this um
does not break anything or there should
be no concerns about the this this part
of the
amendment somebody else want to take a
stab at it representative
yell thank you um
so I believe your question is about
section
two and um the the part
of the law that is being changed is just
the definition of what is considered a
special warrant article and so if you
had a warrant article that was a lease
agreement before apparently it wasn't
considered a special warrant article and
so all this would be saying is that it's
also considered a special warrant
article and so there is no
uh amount of money that would be that
that would be at issue if by calling it
a special warrant
article like that you're just saying
that that this is just article right I
understand right but what I'm asking
is if let's say there was
a when there's a call for appropriation
if now all uh issuance of of lease or
continuing of lease agree agreements
need to be on a warrant article let's
just say there was a lease agreement
that was
[Music]
for $500 or something is that still
going to be included on is that the
intent I'm just trying to figure it out
answer would it be Advantage if I I
don't think that it's necessary could
there's there if you read the thing it's
a it's even talking about like things
submitted by petition so if you had a
petition that had a lease that was $5
right that still is considered a special
warrant article I don't think that this
breaks anything by calling a lease of
special warrant article if it's put on
the
warrant repres it's a very broad
priest thank you Mr chairman uh I also
have the same concerns that you have um
because the dollar amounts aren't there
and so I I have a feeling that even
though the intent was to simplify and
clarify it it now puts all budgetary
lease items as warant articles and I
think that is could be ve have very
unintended consequences for local
governments everything would be up for
debate and vote
how about this how um we have many more
bills we can go through why don't we
recess this particular Bill
until uh I'm just going to put a a Time
on it say of
11:45 that'll give us uh time we can go
through a few more of these and then
come back to this one I just again I'm
to in total agreement on trying to close
this loophole I just want to make sure
we're not doing anything with that line
that's um
not going to work so we'll we'll we'll
recess this one until 11:45 and then
we'll go ahead and move on to a next one
here you said that we would be taking a
break after this yes we will uh why
don't we take uh 10 minutes everybody
again
e
oh my
God
at
was not inton
you can I didn't know so I didn't know
that's
fine okay uh let's get going uh continue
on uh right now we'll go ahead and open
up the exact session on hb1
1210 the election of straford County
Commissioners that would be open do I
have any
motions right representative majori Mr
chairman I move ought to pass on House
Bill 1210 I'll second that
representative who second hackin
Phillips okay would you like to
speak yes thank you Mr chairman yes
thank you
um those of us on the committee we we
have a long history here we we certainly
had disagreements about uh about what
happened how it happened why it happened
last year with the districting of
straford County to go from the one
District uh to three districts uh it is
the intent that uh straford County was
working well uh it was the intent that
to keep straford County working well
that uh that we don't mess with things
uh there were uh we've heard many times
that uh it would be that the bill uh
that was passed last year would allow
for a Better Mix Republicans and
Democrat rats we've heard numerous time
on on County Commissioners we've heard
numerous times that there have been many
Republicans or there have been
Republicans excuse me who have been
elected uh and those Republicans have
also been defeated by democrats it seems
to be the will of the people uh to have
those that they want serving an office
to serve an office so we would we would
urge that this bill be ought to pass and
uh and I thank you for your time
represent kill thank you Mr chair I
greatly appreciate everything that my
colleague adds I I I will disagree that
it was about Democrats Republicans
having having many friends that live in
straford County up north in the farm
country I think this was more about
representation of their their life
choices being versus having all your
Commissioners come from cities having
someone represent those those farmers in
those rural areas and that's not
necessarily Republican Democrat I think
there's Democrat Farmers out there too I
hope I hope so I know we have we have
our our colleague over here um is big on
um composting and things like that so
you know I mean um I'm sure that I I
just wanted to add that I think
that we did have disagreements about the
bill last year and it did pass and I do
believe it became
law
no it did
so um but I don't think it was about
Republican Democrat I think it was about
way of way of life being represented in
your local area local control right
we're always talking about local control
and I think having someone represent you
control further comments represent
priest thank you Mr chairman um I will
be also supporting the utop pass bill
and the reason for this is that the
process
where the previous bill went I really
disagreed with and I believe strongly
that if there
were uh citizens in Stratford County
that felt that their views were not
being Representatives Farmers or no
Farmers there's a process there that has
been working for years and years that
you vote the Commissioners out and you
put in someone that addresses your
concerns and I don't and I believe also
that if there was enough people in
Stratford County that wanted to have
District
Commissioners that there would be a
process where there would be hearings
and discussions and maybe workshops for
people to participate in
in and if that was the will of the
people then that would have happened but
to go about the process where the
previous bill
was was wrong and so that's why I am uh
comments seeing none Believe It or Not
Your chairman has no comments
kidding
go straford County was the only County
of our 10 that for at least the last 40
years that chairman mcgis has ruled the
C
County
um has
been almost 100%
Democrat so let's take a look at why
that
is the county is made made up of
Republicans in 40 years that chairman
mcgis has been there there have been 20
election Cycles follow me on the numbers
here 20 election
Cycles that's 20 elections times three
Commissioners that's 60 Commissioners
that have been potentially or have been
elected in straford
County during those 40 years in a county
that is
58 ratio there have been
two two Republicans
Republican I considered what had been
going on for 40 years and I don't really
even understand how it was allowed to go
on for 40 for years but B basically you
had a county that was geremander by
had
the commissioner mcgis made multiple
multiple statements at our last hearing
here some that are just outright wrong
some that are extremely misleading uh
one of them was that well Republicans
have got elected in the district well
here's here's the
thing you've had two Republican
60 you might have had a republican
Sheriff you might have had a republican
registar Deeds you might have had a
republican occasional something else but
that's not a
commissioner it's not a commissioner
years again we were the only County that
elected at large now if this is such a
great
idea I would ask everybody to go to
their
counties
and ask your Commissioners do you want
to get elected at large I think you
would find the answer to that would be
no but if someone were to bring bring
forth a bill that said that
maybe I would vote for that but in
straford County we want the ability to
aisle the other thing uh representative
McClair mention was that the vote taken
at the house last year was
somehow not valid because of situation
with a current Republican or a repu
former Republican who was living out of
uh his
district the vote on the house floor was
by one vote the speaker did not vote in
that vote which means it would have been
a tie and the speaker would have cast
the deciding vote in
favor going back to what is in front of
us would actually
be very much a jander district jander
district for those of you who don't
understand what the term means is
basically
creating a county a
district that severely favors one party
or the other and that's exactly what we
had in straford county and that's
exactly what we would be going back to
uh If This Were to
pass uh representative mcgis mentioned
that this was unconstitutional no it's
not
unconstitutional um the Senate uh talked
with their uh legal representation
before this bill even hit the floor I
spoke with the secretary of state and
the secretary of state was uh said this
was
totally uh relevant and able to be done
because one by one over the decades each
of the counties had gone this
direction it's not it we did not
redistrict when this bill was our
previous bill passed last year it was
the
districting of the county this this here
redistricting um representative mlar
says on representative uh commissioner M
glaris on multiple occasions has
threatened legal action on this um there
is no court case pending on this there
is no court case in process right now
it's because the court case would never
win it's it'd be a a waste of the
taxpayers
money
uh let's see did I get
everything so for all those reasons I
will be voting against the OTP
motion thank you representative K thank
you Mr chair I I just would like to add
you know to my colleague from my County
Rockingham County if if we didn't have
districts we would have the same
scenario going on in our County
um there would be whole swwa of rural
communities not represented by a rural
commissioner if it understands their
their needs and what they they need to
see happening and and the things that
they're looking for and I just don't see
this as as a power fight I know many of
my colleagues would disagree I see this
as an um we have to represent those
people for for where they live and what
live further comments represent hack and
Philip thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to um
just bring in a voice that I think is
missing from the conversation I know our
ranking member uh representative stavis
is not here today but um I know that if
she was here she would try to remind the
group that you know once we've set a
quote that I think she was picked up
saying was that I quote once we start
down the road of changing electoral Maps
outside the 10e cycle we're entering
dangerous territory unquote and this I
think was in her mind referring to the
precedent that the initial bill sent set
this bill is um attempting to offer a
closing of the door that was opened in
the last legislative term so that
politics would not be these districts
would not be subject to politics in the
future but instead it would be up to the
electorate itself so um you know I just
think there is a hypothetical situation
in the future where different potential
political makeup of this house the
Senate and you know potentially the
governor's chair would be in existence
where they would want to you know
reverse this or and create new districts
for many different counties not just
straford so I think you know we are this
bill is attempting to you know to close
that precedent to make sure that we
understand that that was a mistake in
that you know we don't want politics to
be drawing these Maps every legisl of
term and um for that reason I think it's
important to remember that you know the
people who send us to conquered don't
want their districts to change every two
years based on the new makeup of the
bodies um so for that reason I'm going
to support the ball I think it's
important thank you forur the comments
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman now although this might not
directly apply it it it this happened in
the uh Carol County this past year we
had two
resignations and when after they had the
resignations we had to work to get the
candidates uh from the different
Geographic areas of the county so that
we felt that they were that the whole
County was represented by different
represented by different people and the
whole delegation worked to get a number
of candidates and in the end we voted to
uh replace these people through the
delegation the point being was that we
thought it was in important enough to
represent the entire County and get
people outside of mboro or wolfboro we
had plenty of candidates that were
willing to run from those areas but the
rest of the county did not have that
same representation so we felt it was
important and the uh existing
commissioner also felt it was important
to have representative from
representation from the other areas of
the county so that's what we did there
and I think it's worked out for us
there'll be election to replace these
people this fall and I think everybody
feels that it's important in our County
anyways to have representation from the
entire County thank you for the comments
representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair I I just
wanted to um I guess comment on a couple
of things that I've heard I appreciate
the work that was done in uh
representative Browns District uh or
County um and that's what just what
someone else has said is that you have
to find candidates um you know do that
work and you will get the results that
you want
um the other thing is that uh I think I
think it was Mr chair uh said that
um there's a difference between or you
can ask people if they want to be in a
um districted County or just give them a
districted county and I think that maybe
this is a two
question uh matter and that first ask if
the county wants to have districts and
they may want may want to have four
districts you know I I don't know the
the laws on how many U people are per
District but um I think perhaps this is
a two question idea and so therefore I'm
going to vote OTP to maintain the
current um
status fur the
comments seeing none L the clerk to call
the role on OTP
motion on hb1
1210 thank you Mr chairman
representative power no representative
Guthrie no clerk votes no Representative
lales no representative your
Kella
no represent Kelly Representative awood
no representative Brown no
Representative
kahill
no representative majori
yes representative Muse
yes representative harri Guth yes
representative hackin Phillips yes
representative
Gilman
yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks representative
Heath yes representative priest yes
representative spear yes Mr
to9 do we have another motion
representative power thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to move in expedient
to legislate on House
Bill 12 one0 do we have a second
representative
yella uh do you have any further
comments Representative no seeing none
uh when the clerk is ready if you could
rooll okay itl and hb1
1210 Vice chairman power yes
representative
gby clerk votes yes represent
lales yes uh represent
Kella yes Kelly Arwood
yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
major no representative muse
no uh representative Harry Guth no
representative hacken Phillips no
representative
Gilman no representative Gallagher no
representative hicka representative
Heath no representative Priest No
Representative spia no Mr chairman yes
N9 to9 who would have thought we would
have ended up with a nine to9 vote on
this
bill representative kill would this be
it
okay uh it will go on the regular
calendar uh without recommendation
obviously uh
for
um this I will do the committee report
for our and who for you guys okay
okay all right and with that hb1
is
done okay um going to go back we
recessed HP 1187 until 11:45 it is
exactly
1145 uh what I'm going to do we have two
bills we are already planning to do on
the 20th we're going to recess that one
um also until the 20th and we'll we'll
plan a start time I we only anticipate
probably three bills so we're going to
make it like around 10:30 uh so I'll
just say 10:30 at this point for HB
1187 on the
20th Mr chair could I just make a quick
note to the folks who are working on
that um that bill I'm looking at the
drafting for the
amendment and um I I think they may also
need to take a look at one of the
subsections of the chapter RSA 33 colon
8 what I would suggest is uh once the
day is done you can talk with them about
that but I'm not certain probably an
agreement Happ to do that
yep
okay uh the next bill on the list HP
1223 again that is one we will not exec
until 311 why ises that say 311 never
20th okay okay so next we will go
to HB
1281 relative to zoning restrictions on
residential rental properties open the
exec and representative
oh representative majority you were
going to make a motion
representative how obviously wants to
make a motion uh representative power go
ahead thank you Mr CH thank you Mr
chairman I would like to offer this
committee Amendment
1281 I second there's a second
representative yella would you like to
speak to it thank you Mr
chairman um this is an important bill
and when the bill was introduced here in
committee
I in my um Zeal to be completely
thorough with the wording of the bill
and to ensure that there were no
loopholes and every eye was dotted and
every tea was
crossed
um the bill as introduced um could be
construed as um very perhaps by some
complicated and um difficult to to
interpret while the bill was conceived
in in my head it was very clear and when
I do things I do things very with
intention and I choose my words very
carefully well that being said I um
based on
feedback
and um concerns that were expressed
during the hearing I decided
um to submit this amendment and to be
clear I did um collaborate with a number
of different parties Municipal attorney
stakeholders um the New Hampshire Fire
Marshall and I came up
with a number of different amendments
but I I had to pick one to move forward
and that's represented here in the
amendment in front of you
amendment is less wordy and and perhaps
maybe even more precise so there's two
two things here and what what I did is I
dialed back the um provision to have no
less than two occupants per bedroom in
good faith compromise to make things I
guess
less complex I put that to to one
occupant per bedroom and the other thing
um that's here is that I added in the
sentence that says nothing in the
section shall prohibit the enforcement
of the State Building Code or state fire
code again when I file bills it's never
my intention to break other things I'm
I'm very um cognizant of that and I I I
want to make things work and I take
great pains to to make sure that things
are precise and correct So based on my
discussion with the New Hampshire Fire
Marshal um in with regards to the
wording and looking at um life safety
codes and fire codes he has um provided
this committee his assurance and his
word in writing that he has looked at
this amendment and there is no issues or
concerns with the ability of
anybody to be able to enforce State
Building Code and state fire code and I
would also note that the word State Fire
code encompasses fire codes as well as
Life Safety codes that's a subtlety in
language that people may not understand
so um to speak to the necessity of this
bill New Hampshire has a well-known
deficit of rental house housing as well
as high cost to
rent the New Hampshire Housing Authority
reports from 2023 that the average
monthly rent for a two-bedroom apartment
$1,764 this is this represents an 11.4%
rent increase Statewide in the past year
and we have a
0.6% rental vacancy rate
Statewide where actually a 5% vacancy
rate is considered a healthy
market so an important piece of the
solution to the housing crisis that that
we Face here in New
Hampshire in my mind is this
bill this is a bipartisan
Bill and it has 10 State reps 10
sponsors from the house and two sponsors
from from the Senate and the purpose of
this bill is to prevent M municipalities
from enacting or enforcing local zoning
ordinances that restrict renters to less
than one person per bedroom in in a
residential
rental based on my research at least
eight municipalities currently have some
form of local ordinance that restricts
Property Owners from being able to rent
a single family dwelling to to no more
than three unrelated individuals and as
I um explained quite thoroughly
in um my bill introduction what this
means is if there is a house that has
for example four
bedrooms
reasonably in general based on the size
of the of those bedrooms we're talking
two people per bedroom so that's eight
housing opportunities and in some
municipalities they have ordinances that
artificially restrict the number of
unrelated people that can rent
such a residential rental property so
that would that leaves five in this
example five housing
opportunities not available off the
market when they're sitting there
available these bedro rooms are
literally locked up we can't use
them so what happens yeah these
ordinances forc landlords to leave empty
bedrooms
interestingly and is noteworthy is that
many of these municipalities grandfather
certain select rental properties so they
are exempt from the ordinance and I
would contend that if this
is a you know a real thing
then why why are they grandfathering
properties to be
clear this practice does not lend for a
uniform application of a local ordinance
and it should all give us
pause furthermore these rental
ordinances artif artificially restrict
the number of available bedrooms for
rent decreasing rental availability and
in turn increasing rental costs
as I said the State Fire Marshall has
worked with me and has indicated that
this amendment is compliant with All
State Fire and Building
Codes supporters of this bill are
housing Advocates renters seeking a
place to live and landlords who can if
this bill were signed into law will be
able to fully utilize their properties
in a reasonable
manner make no mistake if this bill were
to be signed into law with the stroke of
a pen it will instantly make hundreds of
desperately needed housing opportunities
overnight moreover over time House Bill
1281 in my mind will actually decrease
rental costs or at least slow the rate
of increase by increasing the supply of
rental units available more landlords
will then be incentivized incentivized
to expand their rental um property
portfolios once these ordinances are
eliminated House Bill 1281 is an
important bipartisan step in resolving
the housing crisis in the granite state
and I would respectfully ask this
committee to please support this
you
spear it's uh it's very nice to hear
that the fire commissioner was consulted
on this
however I live in a very densely
populated community in
Nashua this would completely overrun our
water supply it would overrun our sewer
capability it would overrun our garbage
collection we don't have parking for
this kind of thing and we' see landlords
often from out of state renting
properties with no thought whatsoever to
what the density of the community looks
like when I canvased back in a year and
a half ago I actually went to the door
of someone who came to the gun came to
the door with a rifle strapped across
his chest and I asked him why and it was
because all of the properties around
them had been rented and that he was his
was being used as a garbage collection
place and he was trying to stop it the
problem we have in very densely neighbor
in very dense neighborhoods is the fact
that the renters because they don't own
the property don't end up taking care of
it the way the owners do I think that
this cannot be left as a mandate to the
state we don't have in some communities
we don't have parking we don't have
facilities we don't have water I live
with 18 lbs of pressure water you know
what it's like in the State House when a
bunch of people try to flush the toilet
it there's no pressure and that's what
it's like where I live you literally
cannot take a shower where I live
because of the amount of people on that
water
line it's so the fact is the picture has
to be looked at much more broad before
you to start deciding whether and a a
community can be take can take on the
density that this would allow and I and
as a a result of that I will vote
against
it represent yella
yeah I
um have some concerns about this
amendment I liked the idea of
restricting municipalities from
discrimination
however um I think that often times
municipalities when you put these rules
saying no more
than um or uh reasonable or those types
of things um we've found that
municipalities like for the uh for
um the adus require up to four parking
spaces for a single
Adu of less than 800 square ft and
municipalities take Liberties and
essentially say like when we see
something in law that says we can't do
more than this then we're going to just
do the bare minimum and and I fear that
this might encourage municipalities to
essentially uh
limit um one and family one and two
family dwellings unnecessarily not even
talking about the municipalities that
currently are discriminating based on uh
their the occupants marital status but
actually
discriminating just because this is how
they want to essentially plan their
community and they only want to have the
one um or one people in these two two uh
family dwelling units they want to add
that restriction just as a covenant to
some new building um and I think that is
just essentially encouraging them to do
something like that which I think is
kind of moving Us in the wrong direction
um I am not 100% sure that this is a net
benefit
um just because I think there that the
situations that the representative is
trying to address those those
communities would just adopt a like one
one occupant per bedroom uh restrictions
across the board and I think that would
actually be um harmful
to families um across the state so I
think this is um well-intentioned but I
think there may be some negative
ramifications representative
priest thank you Mr chairman I agree
with my colleague representative ellaa
that it does have
unintended
consequences and even though I believe
that the sponsor has tried her best to
try to um address the concerns that were
raised there's the
underlining
um issue of discrimination of unrelated
persons that we heard so much about in
the hearings and that still isn't
address
and secondly I think it's local control
that should be regulating the number of
persons per
bedroom um and in one Community it may
make sense if they have the utilities
and the resources to handle larger
occupancy per
houses but in others it may not be like
in the case of NASA and in
Manchester um so I think it should be
left up to the local controls to
determine what is best for their
communities and with that um I think we
should oppose uh this amendment thank
you represent maor thank you Mr chairman
um unfortunately I'm I'm going to have
to oppose the amendment and since the
amendment replaces the bill that
therefore then um oppose the bill and
it's not as my friend representative
priest said because I I I don't believe
in what the bill was was trying to do
the government should not be telling us
um about our familiar relationships and
and and and how we are living that way
they and and on that grounds I think
this bill is very important but to my
friend uh representative Ella I agree
the same thing I think that now what's
going to happen with this amendment is
we're going to have one resident per
bedroom because that's what the
community is going to do it doesn't I
the amendment doesn't say that the that
you shall comply with fire codes it say
says you shall not prohibit being on a
planning board for 12 years I've seen
where parsing of words makes a big
difference and if you shall not prohibit
it means there will there is a loophole
there where somebody may not
comply uh I would prefer that that this
bill because of its intent to increase
affordable housing uh and and eliminate
that piece of discrimination or audible
I think this should go to interim study
so we can fix this but I I think as it
is drafted right now it's not there yet
and I I do think we can get there and I
want to get there but right now I don't
think that this B bill can get us where
we need thank
you further comments representative
Gallagher uh so sticking just to the
amendment um and trying to um avoid
discussion of the underlying bill um
yeah I do think that um this amendment
attempts to address some of the concerns
raised with the original bill um and I
think um it's a compromise and um while
I probably would have preferred the
original Bill if this um amendment makes
it more likely to pass then I'd support
it um so um as far as um whether it
deserves more study or not um I think we
can I I think that's a question
independent from whether we adopt the
amendment or not we can vote to amend
the uh um adopt the amendment and then
send it to interim study possibly so I
am just going to vote to um approve the
amendment for
now for the
comments representative haen Phillips
thank you Mr chair
I I represent Handover and lime and as
you know Dartmouth colleges in my
districts and we also have a student
housing and affordable housing crisis in
our community um and I I proface that um
the statement with um saying that I'm
not sure that this amendment really
addresses the issue of trying to
increase you know those
rental property units across your
community with this mandatory language
and I'll I'll tell you why it's I think
um you know our town is much smaller
than the durhams and the the plymouths
and the KE of the state and our planning
board took great expense legal expense
and time and resources to try to come up
with a solution that met our our kind of
rural bubble but high density housing
for on campus and off campus student
housing to address these needs and you
know that response was to create a new
higher density zoning district and to
redefine what a family is and our
ordinances so um you know because of the
current enabling statutes for our you
know zoning board and planning boards um
we were able to meet the challenge um
and help solve the immediate you know
housing crisis with the past student um
calendar year of the students coming to
campus without a place to live so I'm
just saying that I do believe there are
tools that are available to each of our
communities um and that each of our
communities have the ability to address
them in the way that's best seen fit so
I really do think that the way the
current statues exist um provide that
local control which is such an important
piece of how we govern ourselves and of
course while I agree that you know the
housing crisis challenge is meeting all
of us you know at different spots across
the state it is an overwhelming issue
issue and that as many tools as we can
create to try to tackle that um is
important I'm just not sure that the
mandatory language here is going to be
able to get each Community across the
state to that finish line um I think
that you're going to run into a lot of
unintended
consequences um and I I am mostly
concerned about the you know the one
occupant per room and defining who a
family is I think there are
several you know discriminatory and
civil rights issues that still need to
be fleshed out so I would agree with um
representative majori that you know
interim study May provide a better
opportunity to hear maybe even from the
housing um special committee on housing
members to see where they fall um in
line with this as well um so more voices
can participate in that discussion so
thank you very much thank you further
comments representative power
thank you Mr chairman um I I would like
to respond to a previous comment here
with regards to um the state building
and State Fire codes I I found that
comment somewhat confusing because it
goes without saying that those um the
state building code and the state fire
code shall be followed that's the law
and furthermore the wording in this
amendment says nothing because there was
concern before that the the bill as
introduced broke things and that oh you
know building codes and fire codes would
not be able to be enforced so that's why
I put this specific language in that
made it abundantly clear that
nothing in this section and and let me
note that this is under um rental
occupancy so nothing in the section
shall prohibit the enforcement of the
State Building or fire code so that that
was confusing and the other thing that I
that in the course of time when
municipalities are overreaching and
going Beyond in in in adopting
ordinances
that are are violations in overreaches
of the authority that the this
legislature has given them it's
incumbent upon the legislature when we
see those violations when we see those
abuses to step in to look to observe to
analyze and say what you are doing in
your M municipality through your zoning
ordinances it's it's wrong this is a
Dylan's rule state and municipalities
are given the power and the authority to
do certain
things and when they they they take
advantage of that they
overreach and they cause
problems like I said we as legislators
must take note and must take action and
this is one of these
times it's very clear that ordinances
that that leave housing
opportunities empty vacant for no good
reason is a problem it is contributing
to the housing crisis here in our state
and if we choose to do nothing to kick
this can down the road we are part of
the
problem
and I see this as a serious
concern this is why I filed this
bill and I would appreciate it if others
here would recognize the Injustice that
is
wrong I'll just leave it at that thank
you Mr chairman representative kahill
thank you Mr chair um so we do we do
have someone on the special housing
committee sitting sitting right here um
and we all recognize that we need to do
things
to um
work to mitigate our how housing problem
um these are not easy solutions um but I
recognize that there's enough concerns
being raised by some of our colleagues
here today that I would tend to agree
that um possibly an interim study with
that representative majori has suggested
would be the way to
go rep uh repes representative
spere thank you uh I take a little bit
of an exception to saying for no good
reason as I said before in very dense
communities like the ones I live like
the one I live in and I represent it is
very dense we have housing on rental
properties actually on properties as
small as a little bit larger than 1/8 of
an
acre uh we have streets that we
literally have to hand plow we cannot
bring a plow down those streets we have
streets that we've been uh upgrading
because we can't get fire trucks down
those
streets uh as you probably have read in
the news we are both Manchester and uh
nsha are in are not in compliance with
the EPA and the fact that we've dumped
20 million pounds of waste into the
miramac river and into the nashille
river so there are very good reasons for
not increasing the density of some of
these towns as far as deciding what a
family is we have no right to step into
that and then that needs to be fixed if
communities are doing that sort of thing
but the idea of just saying willy-nilly
we're just going to increase the density
in areas that cannot afford to do that
that is also very bad so I think we have
to be very careful where we're doing
that representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman initially I
was in total agreement with the author
of this amendment um I've thought about
it uh quite a bit uh I've listened to
the testimony of my peers here and as a
result of that although I I think it's
well intentioned what we're trying to do
and we're trying to ad just address the
housing crisis I would agree with my per
to my left that uh we should possibly
look at interim study to address this
since uh we don't seem to be able to get
to consensus on it here thank you
further comments representative
yella thank you
um I think
[Music]
that the sponsor of this legislation has
drafted many amendments
um um and I believe
that um these that focusing on
discrimination and ending the
Discrimination seems to be from both
sides to be an
important um issue while
still um not saying that you can't you
you can do other things as far as
limiting um if if there's a need within
the community or there's a um there's a
capacity issue that you might have um
other ways of of limiting but not
through dis discrimination I believe
that um such an amendment could be um
drafted in the time um before this this
bill is is required to be out and so I
think that um I would not support um uh
this amendment but I think that we
should allow this the additional
amendments to be drafted um before the
20th
um and brought brought to this committee
and and and not do interim study before
then so thank you further
comments okay I'm going to take my turn
then representative power you can go
um this bill uh the amendment as well
since we're talking about the amendment
everybody's talking about the bill I'm
going to talk about the bill as as a
whole both of them in my estimation are
unacceptable simply for the well
multiple facts but the main
overriding issue here is like so many
bills we're hearing and that's the
Mandate versus the local control issue
this is exactly another one we've heard
um we've heard from durm planners the
administrator the Town Council we've
heard from Manchester mayor Ru uh Ru
called me and said they were against it
heard from the Lebanon City Manager the
Plymouth Town manager the Keen uh
development of uh director of
development city manager fire chief all
these
individuals have contacted this
committee and there's
a common theme amongst those most of
them all have to do with uh College uh
or university
towns um the issue of whether or not
we're overreaching or not that that's an
opinion but it's the town has the de
makes the decision on zoning that's what
we've delegated to the
towns um the town can make bad decisions
they can make good con good decisions um
and it they'll suffer the effects or the
bonuses of that but that's up to the the
M
municipalities uh to do this um you know
I don't want to get into
the what I believe is really the
underlying reason for this for this the
main bill and the continuing on
Amendment but a couple of the
individuals that testified here I'm not
going to go down that road right now if
we need to later I will um but when we
throw a mandate down on a Town not only
do while the attempt is to protect one
person's property
rights you're taking away the other
person 's property rights the next door
neighbor or whoever who has moved in or
bought or whatever in that locality they
buy
in um for a reason
knowing what the zoning is or at least
you should know one of the individuals
who testified
here um who's in favor of this
that when I asked him when you bought
your first rental property there were
you aware of the zoning and he said no
my realtor didn't tell me Well between
you and I that's caveat
mtor I don't think the realtor is
responsible for laying out exactly what
the zoning is and then I asked him I
said didn't you buy more rental
properties yes well if he was already
aware of the problems in what he
considered problems in the town of durm
why did he continue to you know purchase
F the properties so um it it appears to
me and I spoke
very shortly after our first hearing uh
hearing with Vice chairman power about
this that I saw this this was uh
individuals who are having issues with
the town of durm who were trying to have
us solve solve their issues um the durm
has already at least once and if uh rep
Howen was here he could probably be a
little bit more educ educate us a little
bit more on this
but have been taken to court over over
the their zoning that was put in in the
1980s and they won the courts
adjudicated and said yes what you're
doing is okay so I I just again the
overriding thing for me is mandate
versus local I don't think it's um that
we have the ability or should we do have
the ability but we should not be forcing
towns to do uh do one thing or another
and I would also I know we're not on
that subject but I would also be opposed
to interim study on that um so that's
what I have to say represent
power thank you Mr chairman so I would
just um respond with reference to the
um I guess groups of people that you
have listed those are in fact people
from the municipalities based on my
research that I shared with this
committee they represent the
municipalities that that in fact have
these artificially
in restrictive
ordinances so the other thing that I
would like to say is based on um the
comments here during the executive
session that I would respectfully ask
that um this bill be pushed until
um the the 20th of March as we have
pushed other bills here that have come
before us
because I um have in fact drafted a
number of versions of amendments so that
they're available and like I explained
previously this was the amendment that
that I felt based on my conversations
with individuals this would have had the
best chance to move forward um but based
on the feedback um I would like the
opportunity to be able to
introduce some of my other amendments
thank
you represent gallager um and on the
topic of other amendments I'd also note
that um representative howand had his
own separate Amendment um I forget the
exact number of it um that I think is
worth um considering as well but um
since he's couldn't be with us here
today that um that' be another reason
for um waiting until he can have a
chance to introduce it himself and um
tell us about um his idea behind
it forther comments representative
majori thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm I
think I was the one who first suggested
an interim study I'm not sure based on
what I've heard that interim study is
even going to be the right choice here I
mean just sitting here I'm based on what
I've heard Hanover probably should be
consulted what did you do you know and
how did you do it uh the ACLU probably
should be consulted about the issue of
discrimination uh the courts I I'm I'm
starting to wonder now I I this bill is
absolutely well intended and will do
good things I just don't think it's
ready for prime time right now and
unfortunately that may mean that may
mean it has to go to itl so that we can
draft something that's or something that
better can be drafted that's more
comprehensive I don't think this is a
bad Bill or a bad I don't think it's a
bad idea thank
you all right further comments we are on
the amendment itself uh Mr clerk if
you'd call a rooll on the motion of OTP
on Amendment
1022 Vice chairman power
yes represent Guth
no collect votes yes representative
lales
yes representative
yella
no representative Kelly award
representative
award
no representative Brown
no Representative kahill no
no representative Harry Harry Guth
no representative hackin Phillips
no representative Gilman
no representative
Gallagher
yes representative uh
Keith
no representative Priest
No representative spear
14 okay that motion fails representative
majority do you have a further motion Mr
chairman um regrettably I move itl do we
have a second representative K uh
St I'm assuming since we discussed the
Whole Thing Once the further
comments about the
bill representative gallager um
so uh I I previously tried to keep my
comments just to the amendment and now
since the amendment has not been adopted
um I think there are actually additional
things to talk about
um with the underlying bill um yeah I
think the underlying bill is a good idea
um and that um yeah a lot of the cause
of the housing crisis is zonning
restrictions like these um that
municipalities Institute and that nimes
will um take advantage of to prevent
people from moving in um I to respond to
some of the other points I think I also
represent a very dense District um
conquered w six which is just down the
street and that's one of the things I
love about it is how dense it is um
density provides for walkability it
means there's all sorts of businesses
and other people living around that I
can interact with I don't even have to
own a car um
just because I can I I I really love the
fact that I'm able to walk here every
day and I think more people should be
able to have opportunities like that um
that are brought by density and um as a
renter myself I would object to the
claim that renters somehow care less
about their living space than Property
Owners do um you know it's it's still
like you know if if you if you make a
mess of your living space you still have
to live with it yourself um
so yeah I
um I I think this bill
is a good idea and I'll be opposing the
itl motion on
it for the
comment
Kell yes thank you just because I uh did
not support the amendment does not mean
I didn't don't support the bill the bill
uh even unamended I support and um
believe that that the Discrimination by
some municipalities is um unwarranted
and they're utilizing the
um the
flexibility that the that the state has
given to override uh uh the property
rights of the people um and I have to
disagree with the
representative uh that you buy into the
regulations that you are placed under
when you buy the home um if that was the
case we would never be able to amend
zoning um I think
that there is additional issues as far
as that that
um the
people uh that there are other ways to
address you know everyone in the whole
state has to abide by the state fire
code that is a state mandate right and
so
it's I think that some people are like
wanting to pick and choose what the
state is is mandating and what is not
being mandated by by the state but in
fact when we see abuses that it is AC
incumbent upon us to write those abuses
um and I've you know given examples of
of municipalities abuses in in other
ways than just zoning to this this
committee before and I think that all of
those are are things that we need to be
consider consideration uh considering of
when we are saying like oh we should
just let the local tyranny run run ramp
it and so that's why I'm going to be
voting uh against the um itail motion
thank you further comments
representative
Brown you go to him
first you're recognized go ahead
represent thanks Mr chairman I guess uh
my question is there was a discussion a
few minutes ago about uh the ability of
push this bill back to the 20th uh
before the motion was made was that is
that something that we can still
consider the current motion on the table
is itail once this is completed you can
see okay that's what I want to know
thank you AB
PRI thank you Mr chairman um I would uh
be oppos I would be in support of the
itl because I don't think the bill is
ready for prime time I think think um
restricting the occupants to two
occupants per bedroom is again a mandate
and it should be left to the local
control to determine whether or not they
have the resources and the desire and
the need to do that and then it does
address the unrelated um issue the
discriminatory fact that we've had in
our regulations and I appreciate that
but it doesn't really address that these
regulations should be in compliance with
the life and
safety
um codes of our um safety and fire codes
so and again this can be addressed by
redrafting this thank you forther
comments representative maor thank you
Mr chairman um to the underlying bill I
I I made the motion so I certainly can't
support it but
again sitting on a planning board
sitting on on a select board I've seen
how people abuse things and when I see
language that says shall not adopt nor
enforce any code ordinance bylaw or
regulation it there could be a period
right there because that's the way
people would read it it doesn't matter
what it says after that people will take
that language and they will they will
say you cannot adopt any code any
ordinance any bylaw period that needs to
be addressed again we'll keep saying it
it can be addressed I think it can be
addressed and we can get to a good place
but this bill as drafted is not ready
for Prime Time thank you further
comments represent
P thank you Mr chairman and in response
to my colleagues comments that's exactly
why I put forward an amendment based on
feedback from the bill hearing and
furthermore that's exactly why I have
three other versions of an amendment
drafted and moreover that's exactly why
I asked that this bill be pushed to the
20th but apparently there's no will for
that thank you Mr chairman further
comments seeing none could we ask the
please thank you Mr chairman House Bill
itl Vice chairman power
no represent
Guthrie collect votes no
representative silus
yes representative yella
aood
no representative Brown
no yes thank you representative
K okay representative majority
yes
representative
Muse
yes representative Harry GTH
yes representative hackin Phillips
yes representative Gman
yes Representative gallager
no representative Heath
yes representative priest yes
representative spear yes and Mr chairman
six okay
object I assume so uh it will go on the
regular calendar representative power I
have you down as the committee author
against the itail motion representative
okay okay uh that'll close the hearing
on HB 1281 now we have one two three
four five more to go do you would you
all like to take like a 30 minute 45
minute lunch break or do you want to
push through or no no to what lunch a
break you want a break yeah break all
right it seems like everybody wants a
break so representative power thank you
Mr chairman um we have 16 bills it is
12:30 and I would respectfully request
that we take a proper lunch of 1 hour
thank
you I am not opposed to that myself uh
everybody good with that yes all right
so we'll see everybody back here let's
make it at 1:40 we'll we we'll go an
hour and five minutes how's that one uh
1:40
e
for
in
e
all right welcome back everybody we need
to get going here it
is40 um go ahead and open up the exact
session on hb1
1284 relative to the quas judicial
authority of planning
boards uh representative lales I see
motion could you just turn on your mic
and say that for the people at home I'm
sorry Mr chairman yes I move itl on uh
HB 1284 FN thank you do we have a second
second representative McDonald seconds
that rep uh representative lales would
you like to say anything about
[Laughter]
that sorry Mr chairman I'm not prepared
to speak on the okay rep uh we do have
somebody who would like to speak on it
so uh representative Elward
thank you Mr
chairman members of the
committee I have a lot to say and I hope
me first of all
um this bill is supposed to clarify the
Quasi judicial nature of local planning
boards um I can tell you that the term
quasi
judicial is not defined
anywhere and the average person doesn't
know what it
means so I went to the
dictionary
and understood that when you're
operating in a quasi judicial capacity
uh it's because
your decision is
appealable and when you act in a
judicial
capacity um after hearing uh you you
make decisions um after a
hearing
bill
also um is duplicative of 91a
requirements which is not necessary and
it looks like the bill is attempting to
mandate a code of conduct for planning
boards um which I think is absolutely
necessary
um but go going back to the nature of
local planning boards and and judicial
and quasi
judicial um I did some research and I
found that planning boards um are
also described as having administrative
Powers legislative
powers regulatory powers
and nonregulatory
Powers those last two terms came from
the planning board
handbook that is put out by the uh
Department of Business and economic
Affairs um they don't use the word
judicial in their handbook or quazite
judicial so that that's a problem um
first of
all second of all under this code of
conduct which I think is
necessary because I've been
involved as a citizen activist in my
town um being a at the time a licensed
private investigator and detective
agency owner this was right up my
alley um I was kind of appalled to find
out that our planning
board um doesn't publish their rules of
procedure online the average
applicant wouldn't even know they
exist um they don't follow their
rules they ignore them
completely and that
um thinking this is absolutely necessary
unfortunately
um they also have a separate
section
for um on page the last page page
four um starting on page three Roman
five that a planning board shall adopt
and operate under a set of rules of
procedure according to 676 colon 1 and
goes into various
um situations where planning board
members
can uh applicant can request recusal uh
a butter to any project can request
recusal or disqualification and we
already have
disqualification
um under 673 colon 14 disqualification
of a
member
and they actually use the term judicial
in that section so a planning board uh
member is deciding in a judicial
capacity for various reasons they can be
disqualified
um the ab butter
Clause under Roman
8 the abutter May request a recusal or
disqualification of a specific board
member but it
doesn't say for cause it doesn't say any
reason why they can an applicant can do
the same oh they can only request a
recuse
for cause uh I I hate for cause it's so
vague um
under
673 colon 4 removal of a member they
cite
Malin neglective Duty and inefficiency
as a cause for the selectman to remove
an
in in my
town um we have a ethics
problem uh I was before the board
regarding an excavation
complaint when one of the board members
looked at me and into my camera and said
she can question our decisions but not
our
ethics so I have collected information
on wrongdoing um by members of the
planning board and the zba that came to
light publicly and were
rectified um I feel that there has to be
a way to
prevent people's rights from being
trampled on in in these towns that have
board members who run
unopposed they get on the board
they don't
self-educate they aren't giving any
training materials they're not directed
to the chapter uh that regulates their
conduct and so as I was going through
the be website I
encountered the test that you can take
uh based on the planning board
handbook um one is a certificate you get
a certificate uh at the end of the test
if you pass and the other any you just
take it for
fun um I couldn't pass the one for
fun even though I thought that I I
could um so I wondered and did speak
with Stephanie at um B Anda she was
formerly with OSI the office of
strategic initiatives I talked with her
years ago
and I brought her attention to this
bill and suggested that
maybe what
if once you are seated on the
board uh you were required to take the
certificate
test and each year that you're you're on
the board and you would try to achieve a
certificate and whether or not you
achieve the certificate would be
indicated by your
[Music]
name in the annual
report and this would give um uh
constituents members of the
community um knowledge of the Acumen of
the people who are serving in these
positions
so I support the
itl and I'm rather passionate about this
subject in fact I think that whatever is
implemented for the planning board
should be identical for the
zba and I think that the whole
um chapter needs to be looked at and
those sections fixed that would come in
line with what uh representative oery is
trying to achieve thank
you for the comments representative
priest thank you Mr chairman I will be
also supporting the itl of hb1 1284 I
don't think the uh the bill is necessary
we are already doing this in the
majority of our communities and I can
sympathize with my fellow representative
in her community but I think that's an
exception as opposed to um
what is what is currently going on in
New Hampshire so again I will support
the itl of this Bill thank
questions seeing none uh with the clerk
call a rooll on the itl motion for HB
1284 Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yes clerk votes
yes representative lales yes
representative
yella
yes representative awood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kahill yes representative majori yes
representative Muse
yes uh representative Harry goth yes
representative Hawkins Phillips yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Gallagher yes
representative Heath yes representative
priest yes representative speia yes Mr
zero yes what's your point I think we
had two members walk in after the motion
was made uh representative yella and uh
haric G yeah I believe you're correct uh
just
what's
that it's not gonna we'll we'll remove
them but I think you are
correct was that again um yella
it um hold on one sec Diane uh represent
power U so this without objection will
go on the consent calendar I don't see
any of that uh representative Elward um
I think you would be the person for the
committee
report which I knew representative lales
would like representative power go ahead
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
hear what the final vote was after that
zero okay that closes the exact session
1280 when the clerk gives me the nod we
will proceed to our next one all set
1345 relative to the length of terms for
Coos County
yella um it sounds like an itl to me but
uh yes uh I make a motion at itl thank
you do we have a second I second that Mr
chairman representative Brown seconds
the motion would you like to speak to
your motion represent
Kella um yes I believe that
um
that that this bill is um kind of
perpetuating a problem I think that when
we first heard about Rockingham trying
to and I am a member of Rockingham
Rockingham trying to switch from um two
legislative uh a two-year legislative
cycle to a four-year legislative cycle I
think that it was um some
Representatives trying to do their
friends a favor and trying to make them
not have to run as often I don't think
that it was the
constituents that said oh we don't want
to have this control over this the
county officers like we have control
over the state reps and as we have over
the
governorship it is just people trying to
help out them their friends um I think
that the argument about um you know that
there is it's a complex job and people
have to learn it I think that is no
different than being uh the governor or
uh
even a State Rep um I think that we
learn as we go and we have expertise as
we serve longer um just like they do um
and I think
that there
is
um like taking away the opportunity for
a Mis for the voters to be able to
change course if they chose um someone
that kind of was taking their County in
the wrong direction whether that be the
the the sheriff or the register of deeds
or the uh the County Attorney the County
Attorney wasn't Prosecuting cases or or
um was was uh you
know having favoritism towards someone
or or something I think that the voters
should be able to take action against
that I think that you know just as if
the governor is doing something
inappropriate you should be able to um
vote for the governor to be replaced in
two years I don't think that I I would
not be in favor of of changing our terms
to four years as a state reps I am not
in favor of changing Senators even
though senators are are um you know
have a much more uh full place I'm not I
wouldn't be in favor of changing the
governorship uh to to four years so I
think that 2 years is the correct amount
of time and that we made an error
in uh extending the length of of time
for County officers for Rockingham
County and so for that reason I don't
want to perpetuate um expanding that
error instead um I would prefer to see a
build reversing that kind of like we we
we saw earlier today with uh reversing
the changes on2 I think that um there
was an error made and I think we need
need to remedy that thank
you further comments uh representative
Gilman thank you Mr
chair all right this I'm serving my
fourth term here and every term there
has been one bill from some or other
County to change one or other thing
um uh competitive bidding um
what what
uh number of dollars to start
competitive bidding um this one with the
terms of officers we did it in
Rockingham and you look at the chapters
of the of about the counties and then
there are these carots for a particular
County because of its situation
geographically or it situation
demographically or as far you know
population wise
um and I really want to get working with
the New Hampshire um uh County
Association to figure out that chapter
which is relatively short but each each
uh section of it has a lot of pieces and
that's because every county is different
when we did this uh uh change for
Rockingham County I will say that it was
well let's see how it goes and that was
last year or the year before um so maybe
we haven't seen how it goes but I agreed
with them in that uh the positions that
we're talking about are kind of career
positions um that need this need a a
cons consistent um leadership much like
uh when the governor comes in he can
replace all of the department
Commissioners if he wants to so when a
new new governor comes in they can
replace everybody that's leading any of
the Departments and that would be the
same thing here if we keep on doing the
every twoyear cycle of Elections and and
these folks are bossed by the
Departments ahead of them not by the
voters actually
um although you know we can wait and un
disel them by voting in for somebody
else but I I just want to say that it
makes more sense for this level of of U
Administration to have a longer term in
order to not have to change over
employees to have a consistent work uh
working environment uh than working for
a year and then running for election per
year and having people in their
departments do
um dis not discom but not not
continuously the same kind of work or
Works um outcome s of but thank you Mr
chair representative
Lala
thank you Mr chairman I would uh voice
my agreement with my colleague about uh
uh the
continuity when you have in our case um
and in situations where we have a
two-year term there there are no staff
members that we have to bring along with
us I think during the hearing uh when
the Coos County uh people were here they
made a really good argument to the fact
that you need that continuity of of uh
um of service uh not so much with the
with the uh the people that are elected
but with the staff that comes along with
that and the the systems that are put in
place uh and and so to me that four
years uh makes perfect sense um and the
the the other thing about uh Coos County
and and the point was made that there
are some unique aspects of Coos County
being so Rural and having so many towns
that don't have local police departments
and the fact that we have a foreign
border that borders Coos County and uh
the fact that we have so many
unincorporated communi
up there so to me all of those factors
weigh in to making uh uh that this bill
makes sense to me so I will be voting
against the
itl representative
PRI thank you Mr uh Mr chairman um I
will also be voting no on the um
itl uh for the reasons that have been
stated by representative Gilman and L
Alis um there is a learning curve to
these three professional positions or
four I should say and they you know
whenever you're on a learning curve it
it costs the taxpayers money for them to
be trained as to what is going on and
one year is probably in some cases not
enough and two years they have to spend
a campaigning again for the next year
and so I really think it makes sense
especially for coas County because of
its size and its complexities that this
makes sense thank
you repr kill thank you Mr chair um I
too will be voting against the itl um I
wasn't on this committee a few years ago
when Rockingham County was changed to
fouryear terms but I'm I'm a member of
I'm currently a member of the Rockingham
County delegation and um I think I paid
attention to those hearings and a lot of
the stuff that was said was I think on
average um sheriffs have like sixe terms
around in other states and I think that
that gives the people a a way better
product um because of what my colleague
just mentioned training I mean they have
to go through so much training and learn
that job and and I think it's benefited
Rockingham County that we we've made the
change I mean we're leading the way on
all the drug interjections right now
like we're doing really good things with
our departments our registry of deeds is
unbelievable right so she she's been
doing huge things with um caling all all
our past stuff she's working on a
multi-year project if she had
to stop in the middle of her project to
run and for reelection well and she is
saving us money um so I think that
we we gave it for Rockingham County I
think it would be very hard for us to
say no to another County when their
entire I think pretty much their entire
delegation came here all all their
Commissioners and all all asked us to do
it I think it would be very very hard
for us to say no to them there's that's
and so I'll be voting against the
itl representative
power thank you Mr chairman this is my
second term on serving on municipal
in County government and that is correct
we we had a bill in
2022 um that's been commented upon that
that did change the length of terms for
the Rockingham County officers from 2 to
four
and if so when the bill came before this
committee the committee actually um
adopted an
amendment which because in in the
committee we we thought that it was in
fact a a warranted and a good idea to to
um have that change from the two to four
and the
committee supported an amendment to have
this apply to all of the counties within
the state and that passed out of our
committee um 19 to Z went on consent
calendar however on the house floor it
was removed from the consent calendar
and that amendment was was stripped off
and it was passed just for Rockingham
County so um that all being said I I do
see the value in the cont continuity
that's afforded by changing this from
two to four years that that gives the um
the different offices the positions and
the different offices the ability to be
able to focus on the jobs at hand and
not have to Pivot and start a campaign
um when you have just twoyear
terms and um just to back up with
representative from Rockingham County
said um yes in fact the nine delegation
um members of Co Coos County they did
vote to approve the bill as did the
three commissioners of Coos County to so
um I would support that for that reason
and the reasons stated I I do support
this underlying bill I'll be voting
against the itl motion because with
government these issues we can change
the statute when we have the the support
of the delegation and and the
stakeholders and to me this is this is
what I see in front of me Coos County
wants this so I'm I'm willing to support
that thank you Mr
chairman for the comments representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman um I tend to
agree with my peers that have just
spoken about the fact that it should be
Statewide and the reason why I agree
with it um on our County delegation we
just had our uh uh County attorney
resigned to take another job here in
conquer and uh her Deputy uh was sworn
in as her replacement as she recommended
and he's immediately going to have to
run for for office this fall uh when you
look at attorneys especially in places
like uh Carol County or Coos County the
difficulty to find someone that you
might feel is qualified would take a
little bit more time especially
regarding the learning curve so I think
it's appropriate for this type of
position to be a a longer term and i
would support an amendment to uh make it
the same as Rockingham County thank
you
representative kill I did want to add I
while I I think this is beneficial I do
think that to my colleague if if you
think that this should be changed you
should put a bill in to to change it
back like a separate
bill in the
comments seeing none um I'll make a
quick couple um I'm in complete
agreement with representative
yella um I I believe it was a it was
wrong I wasn't here on the committee but
I believe it was wrong to go to um to
start allowing individual counties to
get away from the uniformity of having
the counties operate the same way I can
give you exact two great reasons why the
terms need to be short uh I don't know
how many of you are familiar with the
sheriff situation we've been dealing
with in straford County uh there there's
a a reason right there alone we also had
a similar situation where uh an elected
attorney was promoted somewhere else um
so now um in my County as we talked
about on a previous Bill the county is a
majority of one party versus the other
there's no election it's just basically
appointed by the county delegation um so
in that case I would like I would rather
instead of waiting four years to see
that attorney be elected did through the
the normal election process as far as uh
Coos we heard a lot of comments
and couple of the things kind of stuck
out one of them was yes the comment was
made yes some people uh Run for the
office to figure out if they like the
job well I'm not so sure that's a reason
to be running for some of these jobs
that that kind of says to me that
they're they're trying to
that it may they may not even be there
for a full term to be to begin with I
spoke about uh our Sheriff's issue and
the removal process and what we've gone
through
there um the other thing was uh one of
the individuals captain of a sheriff I
believe made the comment well this we
don't really have big turnover in Coos
anyway so I'm I'm not
sure um how
much uh time they actually have to spend
campaigning so
I I I again I'm I'm
for almost
recapturing Rockingham County back to a
two-year term rather than expanding it
county by county getting away from the
uniformity so I I will vote in favor of
the itail further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
to call
R yeah 30 45 itl uh Vice chairman power
no representative
Guthrie click votes yes represent vilus
no represent Kella
yes Representative
aood
no representative Brown yes I made
no
right
Representative kahill
no okay Representative majori
no representative muse
no uh representative harri Guth
no representative Hawkin Phillips
no representative Gilman
no representative Gallagher
no uh representative Heath no
representative Priest
No Representative speia
no Mr chairman
to4 okay do we have a further motion I
see representative Cahill's hand up I
make a motion of ought to pass for uh
1345 do we have a second representative
I'm assuming there's probably not a
whole lot of discussion does anybody
have
anything not seeing any when the clerk
please okay OTP
1345 uh Vice chairman power yes
representative G
three I'm
sorry okay thank you click for yes
represent Silas yes representative
Kella
no representative howood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kill yes representative
majori yes representative Muse yes
representative Harriet goth yes
representative Hawkin Phillips yes
repres Gilman yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Heath yes
representative spear
yes uh Mr chair yes forgot me what's
that you forgot me I didn't forget you
I'll get to you
okay representative priest yes okay and
Mr
chairman no okay uh 18 to no 17 to one
minute depends on how you count it brown
thanks he's supposed to be my friend you
know hey man you want to sit over
there okay all right it's okay all right
hold on a
where there any other NOS U besides y
Kellen myself think so
okay 16-2 sounds
correct uh without objection
okay um it will go on the regular
calendar uh for the motion of to pass
who will be writing that committee
report representative Gilman has taken
that one
and representative yella will write
the actually um you know what I'll take
that one Josh unless you really want it
one okay with that uh close EX session
on
okay uh next up HB 1371 open up the
executive session on that relative to
use allowing the land use master plan to
include a section on waste reduction do
I have a motion representative priest
yeah I would make the motion Mike please
thank you I'm sorry thank you Mr
chairman I would like to make the motion
to ought to pass
HB
1371 do we have a
second second representative majori
seconds representative priest would you
like to
speak yes I would thank you very much Mr
chairman I think this is a very
important uh element for community's
master plan and I think it should be in
the sections where it the that the Comm
communities may consider it so it's not
a mandate it's just one of the sections
on section three that they need to
address if they want to like
Transportation or Economic Development
or natural resources but I think it
rises to that element of
importance especially
um in this age where uh landfills are
coming less and less and we need to
focus on how we can reduce the amount of
waste in our communities thank
you further comments representative
Brown yes Mr chairman could you clarify
something for me is there anything in
the current law that uh prohibits them
from doing that anyways without this
change interesting you should ask that
it's one of those issues that I've long
thought that when you get into this
P particular
RSA it's a NeverEnding list of what
towns may
do there's nothing that prevents them
from already doing this they can already
it's just it's it's a master plan here's
what you may consider in your master
plan
um I've always thought it might be
easier just to up on the top and then
don't quote me on this I'm kind of doing
a paraphrase here but and the town may
consider any other items they wish in
their plant this is just adding one more
I don't see it honestly as I'm I'm kind
of in the middle I really don't care
about it I I don't think it's that
meaningful
but hope that answers your question
power thank you Mr chairman I I I can
defer to representative
majority seeing that representative
Brown just spoke no okay so um my
understanding is that this bill would um
statute relative to the master plan and
like you said there's there's section a
through o and this just would add
another one and to be clear that these
are optional
portions so the addition of of this um
particular section on waste reduction to
me causes no harm additionally I'd like
to add that having spoke to um a member
of my local planning board it was
commented to me that by adding this to
this section of Statute that this would
therefore enable the municipality to um
consider and propose uh ordinances um
surrounding this this this issue which I
think is an important tool so I will be
supporting an
OTP representative
major thank you Mr chairman I I will be
um supporting the OTP on this um just
say that I know I'm supposed to take out
the garbage but I don't unless my wife
reminds me and she has to remind me all
the time so I I think it would be I
while I agree any the towns can do this
we already can do this I think it's very
important to have it in front of them as
somebody many of us in this room are on
planning boards and we've sat there and
we know what our role is when we review
and and revise our master plan having it
in front of me just the words I I'm
reminded let's consider this I I think
as as was just said uh I think it does
no harm and therefore it is good thank
you for the comments representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair um I also am
going to in I'm in favor of this bill
and um as representative majori said uh
sometimes people just need a little kick
to start thinking about things and my
town recently went through its five-year
upgrade of the master plan and when and
we presented the list of what's
recommended by the state
um it it got people thinking about well
what's more important is it the energy
section or is it Regional concerns or is
it public service um and we had just
added the energy section last year I
believe or no
um so adding this also uh
um on Waste Management we have another
bill about uh waste management districts
and my t has actually gone into quite a
healthy um series of of waste management
or waste reduction uh but there isn't
any goal set for how much we want to do
it's just here's the tools to use it and
if you put it in the master plan you
need you also need to set a short and
long and Midterm goal to get to the
point of you know we want only 5% waste
reduction this year Etc so again it's
just um adding it to the list yeah it
seems kind of foolish to have this list
and let people you know let Town towns
figure out what they want but having
that little nudge that says consider
these things please I think is a good
idea thank
you further
comments uh representative
Guth thank you Mr chairman I agree that
uh this is uh something that individual
towns could do that do anyway however I
think it's as many of the previous
speakers have said it's a good thing to
have it in front of you not only that I
think the solid waste is probably
depending on how you're getting rid of
your waste is a significant part of the
budgets uh in in the communities and
also it ends up in the CIP Capital
Improvement plan if it's in your master
plan and there could be some significant
major costs uh down the road in uh in
the uh plan for your Solid Waste uh and
this further comments
questions seeing none on the clerk ready
call the rooll please okay HB 1371 OTP
Vice chairman power yes representative
Guthrie clerk votes yes representative
lales yes yes representative
Keller
no representative award yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill
yes representative majori
yes representative Muse
yes uh representative Harry Guth
yes representative Hawkins Phillips yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative Heath yes
representative priest
yes representative spier yes Mr chairman
passes Ved are you well I'm going to ask
you again when I when you confir those
apologize okay uh passage 171 any
objection to the consent calendar
representative yella no all right then
it will go on the consent calendar
and who will be writing represent of
priest
okay okay with that we we close the
1371 and when the clerk's ready we'll
move
on
okay uh executive session on 1460 FN now
open relative to the sale of
County
property I believe representative
McDonald has a motion I motion itl do we
have a second I make the second Mr
chairman representative Brown seconds
the motion of
itl represented McDonald would you like
to speak to
okay this uh what happened up in Cal
County this past year or so I guess it
was we had a uh County building there
was a courthouse Sheriff's Office and
pretty much all all facilities for the
county and uh we sold it to given it to
uh aome Historic Society to run it for a
dollar to put the historical thing in
there and they backed up we couldn't
afford to to heat the building anymore
plus the building has got all the common
things that you find in a 100y old
building sounding the pipes and things
like that so the uh County Commissioners
decided to sell it they put an ad in the
uh in the local paper it ran and they
got two bids they got one from uh a
charter school and another one from a
kind of a developer that wanted to put
Workforce housing or some type of
housings or apartments and and that
would have destroyed the entire
character of the building itself had the
courtroom and things like that that were
important to the community to uh to
remember so uh they put it in the paper
it came before the they did the uh
purchase and sale agreement uh the
Commissioners brought it before the
delegation and we voted to accept the AG
the uh the deal for $1 with a condition
it would stay basically the same as it
is and if there was any issues
financially it would come back to the
county and that upset a few people in uh
in some of the communities um but again
we didn't try to hide anything it was
done through public hearings and public
comments and all the other things and I
think this bill does a little bit more
than than uh it should do this 15 days
to do everything I think is a little uh
outrageous what happens if uh we put
this thing in the newspaper and there's
13 days short to be 13 days now we've
got to purchase and sale I'm going to
come to the county and say now you can't
sell it because you didn't put in the
newspaper for for 15 days I think it
should be left up to individual County
to set up their own policies and rolled
and if uh people in the community upset
with it they can come in and tell the uh
during the hearings for the community
and the rules and the Commissioners
Conde or the delegation Conde and if
people AR happy with us then they can
vote us out but I think this uh goes a
little bit too far uh this particular
itl for count representative uh
representative major thank you Mr
chairman um ditto
but for all the other reasons I mean to
to pass the Bill a property was sold for
a dollar there was no uh there was no
appraisal done for that property um and
and I this what this process will do is
provide for that kind of
transparency uh that is necessary for
the community to the to the extent that
you are trying to preserve the historic
nature of of a building I completely
agree um and I think that that is
vitally important sometimes and I think
people will will respect that they know
what they will be getting I can think of
one Community next to me um where where
that is happening with a with an old
theater uh hopefully it's opening
happening with an old theater but I
think this bill is an important process
by which uh a community can actually
maintain the value and I do mean that in
all- encompassing way of of their
property uh and still provide the
greater transparency to to the residents
of their Community thank you
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman um just for everybody's
information I'm on that same delegation
and from uh what I saw it was a proper
process where we did go out and get bids
we got two bids uh we wanted to preserve
the the historical character of the
facility uh we were paying I think it
was an excess of $40,000 a year just to
keep it from deteriorating at all
um and that there was no interest from
anybody else other than those two biders
in this entire process so it was costing
the county money to maintain it there
was no interest in doing anything um as
you know
there's the availability for charter
schools in certain areas is not that
great and they had agreed to keep the
building in historical condition and
actually they were planning to use the
courthouse as part of their classroom
situation so we felt it was very
beneficial to keep that character in
place and to reduce or eliminate the
cost to the county of $4,000 a year U
and and uh tried to expedite the I
wouldn't say expedite but try to make a
reasonable disposition with this
facility and uh limit the expenses to
the county thank you further comments
representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman I will be
voting against the it on this motion I
think this bill um makes great strives
to be
transparent on the cell of property they
want to
dispose and um I think we uh it gives
the community a chance to weigh in on
the sale we have a project in Manchester
was an old
schoolhouse and but it was very
important to that neighborhood and
originally they were just going to give
it to um another social Organization for
a dollar or some very minimal amount and
there was really concerns uh of the
community that maybe this wasn't the
best use reuse of this facility and I
think a bill like this um would give the
people in the community a chance to
weigh in and come up with the best
reuse and uh for a particular facility
and come up with
restrictions that would uh preserve some
of the if it's historical some of the
elements that are uh that makes it that
way and I think all of the dates that
are in the Bill it says minimum of 15
days um and then up to at at least 30
days so I think a community would give
would be very wise to give as much
notice to the uh to the residents as
possible so that is the reason why I
would vote to itl this to vote against
iing it so another motion can be raised
thank
you further comments representative
power thank you Mr chairman as I recall
um from the bill hearing there are a
number of questions and concerns with
regards to um some of the
um specifications within the language of
the bill and I had the impression that
an amendment would be forthcoming that
some um committee members were were
going to be reaching out to the prime
sponsor to address those issues that
that were raised during the hearing and
due to the fact that no such attempt has
been made and there is no Amendment for
us to consider um for those reasons I
will have to be supporting the it motion
thank you further comments
representative
lales it seems to me that that generally
people on the committee are in favor of
the overall goal of what this bill is
trying to do but it seems like to me
that there are issues with the bill as
it's currently written what I would like
to see h at this point it looks like I
will be voting itl but would hope that
we would come back and build a
consensus to accomplish what the bill is
trying to uh to address so I will be
voting itl with the thought that the
underlying factors of the bill that have
been expressed really need to be
addressed thank you thank you further
comments
questions uh quick comment from
myself agree 100% with the last two uh
speakers um there are many issues that
throughout the hearing we a lot of us
questioned um from both sides of the
aisle the definition of realtor I saw
something that somebody said that's
actually not um the the real term we
need to be in there the 2/3 majority
that was a question minimum of 15 days
uh a lot of us thought that needed to be
more 30 days for the next one we thought
that one should be more qualified
appraiser who's a qualified appraiser um
I I also agree with where the intent is
going with this uh but it's just there's
just too many issues and as
representative power said U I was
expecting an amendment and I kept
wondering when and if it was coming and
it never came so for that reason alone I
I have to vote itl on
it representative p
uh point of inquiry wouldn't it be
better since we're pretty much all in
favor of the concept of this bill to
vote down the itl and put this as an
interim study so maybe we could get an
amendment back that addresses all of
these
concerns the current motion on the table
is itl we we'll do that motion and then
we can proceed from there how's
that
okay further comments seeing none we'll
ask the clerk to call a
rooll okay 1460 itl Vice chairman power
yes representative
Guthrie yes clerk votes yes
representative lales
yes representative yella yes that was a
yes
[Laughter]
okay uh representative aood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kahill
yes okay representative majori
yes that was he yes representative
majori yes representative Muse yes
representative Harriet uh goth bite did
you didn't think you wanted to say yes I
did I
screwed is are you still a yes
I am a no am I allowed to do that Mr
chair you can you can make it a no thank
you I'm a no sorry no that's
[Music]
[Laughter]
what I know yes she twice my head's in
another committee for a minute so can
David
change
sorry no my apologies represent major is
a no thank you ma'am representative
muse
no
uh representative Harry gothro no
representative Hawkins Phillips
no my friend representative
Gilman h
no representative Gallagher
no representative Heath no
representative Priest No representative
spear no Mr chairman
yes N9 to9 okay so that motion fails is
there another motion on the floor
representative
priest Mr chairman I move interim study
for HB
1460 do we have a second
second representative lalis
seconds would you like to speak to it
yes as I previous thank you Mr chairman
as I previously said there are many
things about this bill that we all can
agree upon and we all think are
important but there are some things that
we need to tweak and I think we can use
this time to tweak those items and get
them correct thank
you just a point of
clarification on an interim study this
particular committee this particular
session will not be changing or putting
forth legislation just so you understand
everybody understands okay it was my
understanding that the chairman if he
deemed it was important could use that
interim study to on those bills that
could be corrected am I I will have to
look in I do not believe that's the case
but I can I will check with clerk I okay
I believe interim study is
simply um you get together and then the
chairman decides or the committee
whatever decides on whether or not they
recommend further study in the future or
uh future legislation that's my
understanding thank you but I will
double check for you so anyway uh sorry
to interrupt uh further comments on the
inter room study representative
yella yes um
it's been said multiple times that
everyone thinks that this is uh has some
Merit and I just wanted to uh voice my
opposition to the whole idea of this
bill and so that I'm on the record that
I don't actually think that there is
anything to fix because I don't think
there is actually a problem that the
that the bill sponsor essentially said
that they were asleep at the wheel when
they were voting and this is not going
to wake them up right they need if they
didn't pay attention to the vote that's
whether it's three fourths requirement
or a a unanimous requirement if they're
just not paying attention then it's
going to end up still passing the same
way and they they're going to have some
regret and that's what happens when
you're not paying attention so I don't
actually think that any legislation on
representative Elward um point of
information Mr
chairman other committees hold work
session I I look at work session I was
on labor um and for a couple one term
Finance I don't recall us doing work
sessions and you guys do in labor we
never did I I see work sessions
as kind of what we do here we discuss
before we exec a bill a work session
would be to get together I think discuss
it in advance of coming to an exec
session that's how I would see it we do
our no well well that's how I understand
it anyway that's that's the way I have
looked at it that's the way I have kind
of run the committee
um we each have our caucuses to discuss
the bills and then we come here and
um so that's how I see it whether
it's the way to run it or not that's the
way I've chosen to run it representative
uh uh
spear uh I'm on usually on Commerce and
commerce has work sessions all the time
but the work session happens before the
execu session it happens after the
hearing before the exec session in which
we all get together and say this is what
we heard let's get some more information
let's modify the bill let's do what we
can to make it right so when we go to
the exec session it's just one right
after the other you know everything's
been hashed out already so once we've
gone to exact we we don't go back to
work
session any comments on the motion of
interim study
Brown representative Brown repres thank
you Mr chairman I just before we vote on
interim study I just like to make sure
that everybody's clear I was on the
delegation that voted to do this
everything was upfront above board
everybody knew what the process was and
everybody voted dispose of the property
and it was done in public session so
there was no uh intent to do anything uh
other than above board I want to make
sure everybody understands it thank
you representative kahill you have
comment on the motion of interim study
yeah even if we vote to do interim study
isn't our deadline next week like say it
again like what could we accomplish in a
week nothing right and I would take that
to mean you'll be voting against the
motion of interim
study
that's not for me to answer
representative y the process for interim
study is that you report out by November
like it's not happening in the next week
that we're studying it
so I hope that
clarifies so thank you I was assuming
everybody knew that it was a fall action
but thank you representative yella
further comments on the in motion to in
study yes sir uh representative Priest
Point of clarification a if the motion
for interim study passes couldn't the
sponsors of this bill come back with an
amendment for us to consider no okay
thank
you
comments ask the clerk to call a rooll
on the motion of in study good luck on
you representative Vice chairman power
no representative Guthrie
no click votes no representative
lales
yes representative your
color a no that's a no a no a no okay
thank you uh representative Allwood
no representative Brown
no Representative kahill
yes representative Muse
yes uh representative Harry goth
yes representative Hawkins Phillips yes
representative
Gilman
yes representative ative Gallagher
yes representative Heath yes
representative priest
yes representative spear
1028 okay motion passes 10 to8 on the
motion of interim study uh
representative McDonald I assume you
will write the committee report against
the interim study motion is that correct
okay who would like not a lot of
confidence in that voice but I guess you
were
yes and who would like to write the
committee report in favor of the interal
study representative priest going to be
a busy guy representative priest all
these
okay all right with that that closes
1460 okay we have one more uh but after
we do this this will be a quick one
please do not get up and leave it just
got couple things I have
to legally do here not legally but
properly do uh we'll go ahead and open
up the exact session on HB 1506 relative
to required votes to approve issuance of
bonds and I see that representative
this yes I move um itl on HB
156 and do we have a second I second the
motion representative kill
seconds representative Elward would you
like to speak to it if you don't I can
yes you will speak to it yes sir okay go
ahead thank you Mr
chairman um apparently the sponsor was a
noow so we have no information to U make
any
decisions very good
comments seeing none uh on the motion of
itl
hp56 when the clerk is ready we could
call the
roll
e
okay here we go with the uh roll
call okay 1506 itl uh Vice chairman
power
yes representative Salas yes uh
represent
Kella
yes representative award yes
representative Brown yes representative
kill
yes representative majori yes
representative Muse
yes U representative Harry gobright yes
representative Hawkins Phillips yes
representative Gilman
yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Heath yes
representative
priest yes representative spear yes Mr
chairman yes 18 to zero okay that Will
Go On The cons set calendar unless
there's opposition seeing none that
156 okay uh chrisy oh representative
power go
ahead thank you Mr chairman I don't
recall who's going to be writing the
report oh thank you very much on 1506 I
see the name lward by
that thank you for pointing that out
represent car
right okay earlier when we did the uh
what was it 1284 I was here in the room
when you made that um motion and gave it
to miss edwell I had an important call
so I left the room after that so my vote
should actually
count that that's fine if yeah somebody
I think we were under the impression
that you came in under I did come back
afterwards okay we'll we'll change that
not going to make uh I know but we'll
change it and as well yet representative
of yella after I check with the clerk I
will
also re redo that if it's yeah thank you
it's not a big deal but I understand but
I we do want to get it right yeah okay
uh Christie if you would listen to this
that way you can just put it into the
calendar for next
week HB 1223 we are going to recess
20th HB 1187 we will recess till 10:30
a.m. on the
20th and HB 1181 we will recess until
10:45 on the
20th thank you very much uh number
two representative Brown and
yella representative Brown and
yella um reports again please have them
done as quickly as possible no later
than noon because I got to get those in
and last but not least thank you very
much for all the subs who joined us in
Municipal and County thank you for your
uh attendance and with that we will see
everybody
Thursday Mr chairman what time are we
meeting again on on
3:20
uh the first one will be at 10: a.m.
okay it'll be noticed in the calendar uh
even though we recess they have to put
it in the calendar so it'll be there and
you'll get a
scared
e